will be covering this week many of these
events are open to the public look for
them to air in the near future
and now on book tv we're live with
author and sports writer dave zirin
mr zirin's books include what's my name
fool
sports and resistance in the united
states
game over how politics has turned the
sports world upside down and the
recently published biography jim brown
last man standing during the next three
hours it's your chance to talk with dave
zirin via phone social media and email
dave zirin thanks for joining us here on
the super bowl sunday
how did this day become a
pseudo-national holiday that's a great
question first and foremost can i say
i'm so happy to be part of the
alternative c-span programming for super
bowl sunday this is the pre-game show
that everybody's tuning in to i think
they're turning away from the networks
away from espn for for our slam bang
affair
but i think you can't understand the
growth of super bowl sunday as
a national holiday first of all without
understanding like the invention of the
television set because before 1950
professional football was really this
secondary sport i mean it wasn't
something even close to boxing or horse
racing even
it was in the in the background really
if you will because it didn't really
play on radio i mean think about the
rhythms of an nfl game
but once television became a part of
people's homes and keep in mind 1950
less than 10 of american homes have
television sets by 1959 it's 90 percent
post-war boom the growth of technology
the spreading of suburbanization the
growth of the television set and nfl
football fit perfectly into that matrix
and so in the late 50s you have what was
called uh the greatest game the game of
the century between the baltimore colts
and the new york giants that ended in
overtime with alan the horse amici going
over the goal line and that became this
remarkable event that was the the water
cooler game that everybody started to
talk about and then into the 1960s with
the with title town and green bay and
the growth of vince lombardi and the
ascension of the super bowl and then
1969 where the great team from the
american football league the the new
york football jets led by joe namath and
his promise to beat the baltimore colts
after that super bowl three i think it
was done america was fully
in love with this new national holiday
that is super bowl sunday and it is
worth pointing out that you know we live
in a time where there are tons of cable
channels of course people are on
facebook twitter social media there's so
much uh incredible um
focus on on alternative medias and
people's uh there's so much competition
for people's eyeballs and yet the super
bowl year in year out draws in more
viewers
that is a remarkable thing
on this cultural landscape so whether
one loves the super bowl whether one
hates the super bowl people are tuning
in and they tune in for all sorts of
reasons as well you don't even have to
like the teams i can't stand either of
the teams playing today i'll put that
right on the table can't stand the new
england patriots because i'm from new
york city and so i'm genetically unable
to root for any team from the boston
area and the los angeles rams not a fan
of this team i don't like teams that
move that breaks the holy rule of sports
they wear the st louis rams now they're
los angeles rams don't like that and
because that it just it hurts fan bases
and it hurts communities so
despite that though people will tune in
they'll tune in to watch the commercials
they'll tune in to watch the halftime
show they'll tune in for all sorts of
reasons and people will hold parties
just for the purposes of watching the
commercials
i mean so that's really to do a very
long answer to your question i mean
that's really where we are with the
super bowl the one thing i'm very
surprised about is that they've never
moved the game to saturday or declared
the monday after the super bowl a
national holiday so people can recover
well the department of homeland security
has declared this as a national security
event yes and sends secret service down
for this now oh yeah no and since 9 11
the whole uh temper
of the super bowl has changed in a big
way it becomes this kind of national
security event where um i mean it's kind
of like a miniature version and i've
written about this a great deal of the
olympics in the world cup where you have
debt the militarization of public space
and displacement that takes place
for the purposes of creating this
security zone around the super bowl
for the purposes of as you said homeland
security because it's seen as a
target
for terrorist actors but that in and of
itself i mean produces a tremendous
weight on the shoulders of the
communities
themselves and there is a tremendous
photojournalistic article in today's new
york times about uh the largely
african-american neighborhoods that
exist in the shadow
of this year's super bowl
and of the mercedes-benz stadium which
is the latest new stadium in the atlanta
area and how these communities have
suffered
in the shadow of the super bowl so it's
a fascinating look at what i would argue
has become a substitute for urban policy
in this country which is the hosting of
these kinds of mega events and why there
is such competition to host an event
like the super bowl and you almost have
to have a new stadium to host it anymore
correct that's absolutely correct warm
weather city i mean well last year was
in minnesota
a state we know very well but but that
was illustrative in and of itself
because it showed the ways in which if
you are able to get your city or state
to pony up a billion dollars for a new
stadium the nfl will look upon you with
favor even if it means
holding their annual prom for their
corporate sponsors uh in an environment
that is involves sub-freezing weather so
the mercedes-benz stadium right next
door to the georgia dome which got
imploded
did arthur block pay for arthur blank
yeah
pay for this or did the community it was
amazing
it was hundreds of millions of dollars
in public money went into building the
mercedes-benz stadium and um arthur
blank as this article in new york times
details has attempted to
like fund community programs in the
areas around the stadium
but you know churches were knocked down
to build it communities were displaced
to build this stadium and so he's
attempted to do some charitable or
philanthropic good works to make up for
the damage that the stadium has caused
yet now there's fear that the money that
he's investing in these neighborhoods is
going to lead to an onset of
gentrification and people who live in
very precarious housing are actually
going to be forced out which is another
feature of what happens when stadiums
get built in neighborhoods is the areas
around them uh become more high-end and
more tony and you know that makes a lot
of the folks who live there have to be
forced out i mean we've seen that in
washington d.c with the capital one
center where the wizards and the
uh capitals play which you know of
course used to be the verizon center
used to be the mci center and before
that it used to be chinatown
and and now it's only chinatown really
in regards to the the starbucks and the
fuddruckers have chinese lettering
underneath
the names of these big branded stores
and there actually is now very few
actual chinese and chinese american
people left in chinatown and it's
because of the role that gentrification
plays when these stadiums come into
neighborhoods
howard cosell and you talk about this in
your book game over
said that politics and sports
should not mix yeah he was saying rule
number one of the jokocracy
is that sports and politics should not
mix and howard cosell was somebody who
is very political as a person and he was
talking very specifically about the way
as he put it the jockocracy would
function like the elevation of former
players like his uh hated broadcast mate
frank gifford would be elevated to these
heights as a former jock and because he
was a former jock he's somehow given
this platform to be able to speak out
and that the way that and he was saying
this really as a critic of the jokocracy
and this idea that if you wanted to
speak about politics in this in this
construct
you would find yourself isolated you
would find yourself iced out
and you would find yourself without a
place in this world so if you want to be
somebody who is a sports commentator if
you want to be somebody
who's an ex-athlete who wants to be a
part of this world or even if you're a
current athlete who wants to use your
hyper-exalted brought to you by nike
platform to actually say something about
the world you will pay a price for that
and that is the rule of the jockocracy
and of course we are watching this game
this year um the the shadow of colin
kaepernick the uh former san francisco
49ers quarterback who i would argue has
been colluded against to be kept out of
the national football league his shadow
looms so heavily over this game
and i could explain how if you like but
just because he violated the rule number
one of the jokocracy about mixing sports
and politics because he protested police
violence and racial inequity during the
national anthem by taking a knee and
because he did that even though his last
season he threw for 16 touchdowns and
only four interceptions he finds himself
without a job in the nfl and now for two
years he's been i have this ongoing
collusion case against the national
football league but for this year's game
for example you had a ton of high-end
halftime acts uh like like rihanna like
cardi b
i don't know if that's the first time
cardi b's been mentioned on c-span i'd
be very excited if i'm if i'm that
trailblazer in that regard uh pink
otherwise known as alicia moore all of
these artists refused to play at the
halftime show
out of solidarity with colin kaepernick
and it created this kind of artistic
picket line where it was very difficult
for them to for them to find uh musical
acts uh who could actually come and play
the halftime show which is which has
been this um this this sub story it was
it's been such a story actually i called
it a sub story like a subterranean story
that isn't really being talked about
with the super bowl but it's such a big
deal that this year the national
football league cancelled their annual
big press conference with the halftime
acts because they were scared that
groups like maroon 5 were going to be
pressured by the by the press to say why
are you performing and when so many
artists are saying they're not going to
do this in solidarity with colin
kaepernick
uh well so nike in a sense is a good
corporate citizen by taking colin
kaepernick on as a client and
and building an ad campaign around him
is that correct well it's interesting uh
nike uh has taken part in what is now
referred to on madison avenue as woke
advertising
and it's this idea that if you appeal to
people's
social justice instincts and if they can
identify a product
with positive social justice attributes
for people who believe of course that
colin kaepernick is pushing forward a
positive progressive agenda then that
can actually help the product itself and
for nike
we've already seen this it's proven to
be very lucrative i mean people might
remember when nike unveiled its colin
kaepernick campaign there were
predictions by the president of the
united states his name escapes me but
the president of the united states uh
said that nike would suffer terribly uh
for this ad campaign
other peop country music artists they
put out tweets where they took socks
with uh the nike swoosh and they cut
them up and and it was like this is
going to be the future of nike it's
going to be destroyed well the opposite
took place nike's earnings shot through
the roof
because of the association and it proved
to be very lucrative and
this is important to this weekend is
that nike also produced a colin
kaepernick jersey a black and white
jersey with his number seven on it and
this weekend people like lebron james
and kevin durant the two most high
profile stars arguably in the national
basketball association photographed
themselves wearing the jersey
so it's like his shadow over this game
two years after he's actually played in
the national football league
is substantial
so
is it fair to say dave zirin that nike
saw this as a money maker yes
oh i certainly think so and i mean nike
doesn't do anything for free uh and it
doesn't take prisoners um so i i view it
as a very canny attempt by nike because
this is something nike's been doing for
over 30 years which is they take
what's on the pop cultural edge they
take rebellion and they strip it of its
content i mean they were the people who
brought in a person who at the time was
a little-known independent filmmaker
named spike lee
to film with michael jordan these
incredible black and white ads about
it's got to be the shoes
and he says no mars and he goes no it's
got to be the shoes
and they also they had an ad campaign
with
um john mcenroe
at the height of his tennis powers and
the adline was a rebel with the cause
with a cause he never found out what he
was rebelling against and you never
really found out what the cause was yet
john mcenroe was a rebel with a cause so
this is really not new for nike uh and
to me it's just the latest iteration of
them you know attempting to take
rebellion and strip it of its political
content and then repackage it and sell
it to consumers
that being said
it also i think had a very positive
ripple effect when they did so because
it showed a lot of athletes that okay
you may violate rule number one of the
jokocracy you may find yourself on the
outside looking in of the sport that
you've dedicated your life to but that
doesn't also mean you're going to be
thrown into the memory hole you know
you're not going to be a commercial
afterthought you are somebody who can
re-emerge
um
stronger if you will even without a
league that
you know that that could damage your
brain and damage your body and
so you can almost have your cake and eat
it too i want to show you some video
from september 22nd 2017.
get your reaction to this
wouldn't you love to see one of these
nfl owners
when somebody disrespects our flag
to say get that son of a [ __ ] off the
field right now out he's fired
he's fired
racism i think that
um i think that that's how do you see
racism i see because this was very
clearly
that that speech was in rural alabama
and it was very uh clearly meant to do
what what this president does best i
would argue which is demonize and divide
people
and in this case you you have a very
specific set of circumstances where
almost entirely black nfl players were
taking this stance not against the
military and not against the flag they
were so specific about that and clear
when they talked about it but they were
taking a knee to speak about the gap
between
what we are told the flag in this
country represents and then the lived
reality of african americans in the
united states particularly in their
interactions with the police
taking a knee is a long-standing
political protest it dates back
at least to dr king and it dates back in
sports uh to 1959 when a uh a track
runner sat during the anthem i believe
her name was uh
rose robinson i will look that up in the
break but rose robinson in 1959 to
protest the cold war and the nuclear
buildup sat during the anthem so this
was nothing new and so instead of doing
what i would argue a president would and
should do which is try to engage
intellectually with why people are
actually taking this extraordinary step
instead he chose to demonize and divide
and can i say something really
interesting is as we're doing this
interview right now the transcript of
donald trump's face the nation interview
has already been released and he's asked
about this and it's very interesting to
see like how his how his tune changed he
he didn't say anything about sobs to
face the nation he didn't say anything
about they should be fired he was asked
about colin kaepernick in the protests
and he said well you know we were able
to pass prison reform which president
obama was not able to do so he
immediately like took it to
this achievement about criminal justice
reform and then pivoting to criticize
president obama and i just thought that
was a remarkable pivot
away from the kind of uh raw meat and
potatoes these are sobs and they should
be fired for disrespecting the flag and
disrespecting our military instead he
was like well uh you know we're trying
to do criminal justice reform so that's
a very different kind of answer
interestingly when he made those
speeches in that same speech i believe
in the clip that you showed
he also made comments about how the nfl
has gotten soft
and about how it's not a serious
physical league anymore for real men and
all this sort of like manly toxic
masculinity stuff about how for real men
get hurt playing football and the
league's trying to eliminate that
he was asked by face the nation how he
would feel about his son his 12 year old
son playing football and he said it
would cause him tremendous concern so
those are two pretty significant pivots
from the political line on the nfl that
took place and part of me wonders
uh if this has to do with the 2018
election results part of me wonders if
this has to do with the fact that nike
did not go down in flames when they
embraced colin kaepernick i don't know
what the reasoning was uh behind this
but the pivots themselves to me are are
significant relative to the raw meat and
potatoes that were being served up
before well dave zirin your book of
people's history of sports in the united
states the subtitle is 250 years in
politics and sports well that's the
thing i mean it's called uh howard
cosell as we said called it rule number
one of the jokocracy that sports and
politics don't mix yet sports and
politics have always mixed you know one
of the questions i sometimes ask people
just for fun is i say who is the first
president to ever invite a sports team
to the white house for a pr event
and may i ask you just for fun or should
i
uh william mckinley you see that's a
that's a great answer william mckinley
is a great answer oftentimes people say
uh john kennedy or people say richard
nixon knowing that they were both big
sports people or theodore roosevelt
because of his interest in sports and
then i say to folks no the answer is
actually johnson
not lyndon johnson andrew johnson goes
back to 1866
where he invited a professional baseball
team
to the white house
for a media opportunity and because
johnson was very cannily using baseball
as a way to speak about the nation
coming together in the wake of the
freaking civil war
so you know
i mean so think about that i mean you
had a civil war in the united states you
know thousands of people dead in in the
fields of this country and there needed
to be an effort to bring the country
back together and so baseball was seen
as the way to do that by andrew johnson
and then it was seen by as the way to do
that by uh the people who promoted
baseball after that particularly albert
spalding as in spaulding sporting goods
who made up this idea that a general by
the name of abner doubleday invented
baseball in cooperstown new york there
is no record and that's why the baseball
hall of fame to this day is in
cooperstown new york now there is no
record whatsoever that abner double day
ever set foot in cooperstown new york
and there's no idea that we have if he
knew the difference between a baseball
and a rattlesnake
yet abner doubleday was put forward
because he was this civil war general
hero so it was this idea of associating
baseball with war which meant
associating baseball with patriotism
which meant associating baseball uh with
the with the northern army and the
coming together of the country following
the civil war so we've seen a few sports
teams say no to going to the white house
after a championship during the trump
administration is this the first time
this has happened well you've had
individual athletes refuse to go
to the white house over the years for
political reasons you had um
for example a goalie by the name of tim
thomas for the boston bruins who's on
the right side of the political
persuasion who wouldn't go meet with
president obama
you had
different players during the bush years
who would not go
i think one of the most famous ones was
back in 1992 when you had a player by
the name of craig hodges of the chicago
bulls who did go to the white house he
showed up uh wearing a daishiki and he
gave a letter to president george
herbert walker bush uh outlying
outlining uh some of his issues with the
state of the united states with regards
to the war in iraq and with regards to
race and race relations so
once again it's like this is not a new
thing of players attempting to
not just merely be photo ops for a
president yet in the trump
administration we've really never seen
anything like this in terms of athletes
particularly black athletes refusing to
go to the white house because they
object quite explicitly and specifically
to who is in the oval office
going back to craig hodges we
interviewed him on book tv that was not
a career-making move for him it was a
career ending move for him and craig
hodges was one of several athletes in
the 1990s another one was mahmoud abdul
rahoof for the denver nuggets who
protested during the national anthem
sound very familiar that was 1996 and
they found themselves drummed out of
their leagues and so people talk all the
time today about why is the nba more
accepting of protesting athletes than
the national football league but the nba
has its own legacy of these political
athletes finding themselves without a
home
precisely because they use their
platform to speak out about politics
they violated rule number one of the
jockocracy and i think one of the big
game changers between the 1990s and
today has been social media and the ways
in which players
and colin kaepernick being example this
in the nfl but certainly in the nba
players they build their own personal
brand and they build it around politics
and they develop a following that makes
it a lot more difficult to marginalize
them like i think if
craig hodges was around today there
would be like hashtag sign craig hodges
or mahmoud abdul rahoof hashtag mahmoud
there would just be so much ferment
surrounding their political situation
that it would have been very difficult
to marginalize them and remove them from
the sport
from a book you co-wrote with michael
bennett seattle seahawks now with the
philadelphia eagles now with the
philadelphia eagles things that make
white people uncomfortable is the name
of the book that was his title he wanted
to call it things that make white people
uncomfortable at dinner
which i thought was funny well we've
covered this book as well on book tv but
here's a quote that's what it makes me
so uncomfortable when people on the
business and accounting side of my life
ask
how are you building your personal brand
it rings so ugly in my ears because a
brand is a product yes i mean i think
michael bennett is one of the most
extraordinary and exceptional people
i've had the privilege to meet while i
was well i've been doing sports the
reason why i did the book with him in
the first place is because of who he is
michael bennett and he asked me to work
with him and i'd
i met michael bennett on a stage in
front of 750 people uh in seattle at
seattle town hall i was asked if i would
interview him publicly several years ago
and that is where i met him was on stage
and uh we we just we vibed so well and i
was so moved by what he had to say that
afterwards he said hey i'm really
thinking about doing a book
uh things that make white people
uncomfortable at dinner and i said well
i don't know about the title uh we might
need to do something with that but i'd
be honored to work on this with you and
when michael speaks about that about
brands i mean
it rings so true because
that we are at a point right now where
athletes are like corporations with legs
and they have a whole set of people who
work for them and work with them they
have the person behind the person behind
the person who is easier to get to veto
corleone than it is to get to some
athletes you got the guy behind the guy
behind the guy and michael's somebody
who just you know walks the streets
where he lives and lives his life and
does community activism and you know you
don't have to get through people to get
to him and he's trying to live an
authentic life in a very inauthentic
world which is the world of professional
sports
well good afternoon and welcome to book
tv on cspan2 this is our monthly
in-depth program one author three hours
and your calls
this month it's author and sports writer
dave zirin he is the author of several
books he's also the nation's sports
editor and writer
here is the nation magazine i should say
i was gonna say
very much here's here here are his books
what's my name fool sports and
resistance in the u.s came out in 2005
after that it was welcome to the terror
dome
muhammad ali handbook came out in 2007 a
people's history of sports in the u.s
came out in 2008
bad sports how owners are ruining the
games we love was his next book and then
a co-authored book with the john carlos
story about the 1968 olympics
and some background to that as well game
over how politics has turned the sports
world upside down 2013 brazil's dance
with the devil the world cup the
olympics and the fight for democracy
and then things that make white people
uncomfortable we've mentioned that
co-authored with michael bennett and his
most recent book just out last year jim
brown last man standing
and we'll be talking about all of those
books all the topics in those books but
we want to hear your voices as well the
numbers are up on the screen 202 is the
area code 748 8200 for those of you who
live in the east and central time zones
202-748-8201 if you live in the mountain
and pacific time zones now if you can't
get through on the phone lines you still
want to make a comment we've got some
social media avenues for you we're going
to scroll through those as well you'll
see them on the screen just remember at
book tv is our handle for all of those
may i say if i could you mentioned one
book bad sports how owners are ruining
the games we love and just to say that i
was inspired or what's the opposite of
inspired d inspired inspired i was
inspired i was despaired to write that
book by being a long time resident in
the washington dc dc area and seeing dan
snyder the owner of the washington
football team and the ways in which over
the the two decades i've lived in this
town the ways in which that football
team went from being the sun around
which all social life not just sporting
life revolved to now being at the sort
of thing where people are tired of this
team people are exhausted with this team
people are exhausted with the owner of
this team people are exhausted with what
he's done
to this organization and seeing that and
seeing the way it actually hurt people i
cared about people in my barber shop
people
around me and also seeing the way
consciousness really grew around the
name of the team and how it was seen as
something that was a racist name a slur
and his inability to have any sort of
sensitivity towards that issue
whatsoever i mean that's really what
inspired me to write that book in
particular although he's certainly not
the only owner i speak about well you do
a whole chapter on dan snyder in game
over but you never said the word
redskins no i i don't say it as a point
of uh
of pride and of work i have a radio show
um here in dc on the pacifica network
and that's actually a rule at pacifica
that we don't say the name we say
burgundy and gold we say the washington
football team
but we don't use the name itself and you
know that's something that that we stand
with proudly and i try to adhere to that
no matter what media i'm on what has he
done
dave zirin to earn a full chapter in
game over i mean there's so much i mean
there there were there are some
individual cases of just such terrible
pettiness like uh like suing season
ticket holders who are unable to renew
their tickets uh bankrupting a woman
miss pat hill which was a story that got
a lot of publicity here uh locally in
washington d.c uh there's the ineptitude
of hiring and firing coaches of um
enforcing his will on the club there's
the the amount he charges for the
littlest things at the stadium uh and
the just the the chintzy way he operates
the franchise uh finding that he was
buying bags and bags of
of of airline peanuts and attempting to
pass them off as fresh to to the fans i
mean so it's like it's the small
indignities and then it's the big things
as well and at present he's attempting
to secure a ton of public funds in real
estate to move the team into washington
d.c
including attempting to push some
legislation into the congressional
budget that was not able to be passed
at the end of 2018
and so you know in all of these ways you
have dan snyder as this person and
coupled with that with his utter
inability to try to talk or meet with
people particularly in the native
american community who object to the
team name
it's just become the sort of thing where
it's been exhausting to have him as a
leading sports figure in the dc area
well i've been around washington long
enough to to remember when
everybody here ate
breathed drank yes the team the redskins
and
it seems to have faded over the years
the franchise is still
very valuable right well um
there's this expression about being an
nfl owner that it's like being a
bartender at spring break i mean you
would have to be utterly incompetent to
not make money and the thing though
about this particular football team is
like when i moved here it was by far the
most lucrative franchise
in the national football league it was a
national brand
and yet today i believe it's number four
on the list of most valued franchises
with teams like the patriots and the
dallas cowboys ahead of them and nobody
sees them as a national brand i mean
it's not the sort of thing like with the
cowboys if anything they're whatever the
negation of a national brand is like you
go to a washington football game against
say the philadelphia eagles you might as
well be in philadelphia you go to a
pittsburgh steelers game here in in
landover maryland you might as well be
in pittsburgh i mean the opposing fans
now come out in full force and take over
the stadiums it's nothing like it used
to be at rfk stadium where the whole um
the whole stadium was just rocking with
burgundy and gold i mean those days are
done they are as they say dead as fried
chicken
so can the nfl fire an owner the nfl
cannot fire an owner
what they can do
is force them out if the owner acts in a
way that is seen as not being in the
best interest of the league and that's
true of all the sports leagues you think
about donald sterling being caught
saying racist things about magic johnson
and that being such an embarrassment to
the nba that they in effect forced him
out i mean we could put the word forced
in quotes he was forced to sell his club
for two and a half billion dollars i
mean we would we all should be so lucky
to be forced out in such a kind way
but but that's really the only way to
have an owner leave if they do something
so incredibly embarrassing i mean just
being a terrible franchise owner is not
enough to get you
out of the league although if anybody
would qualify it would be dan snyder
laura ingram
had some comments about basketball
players and their political activism
espn host carrie champion asked james
and fellow nba star kevin durant about
what she described as trump's racist
comments
i feel like our team as a
as a country is not ran by a great coach
it's not even a surprise when he says
something it's not even surprise it's
like laughable it's like that's bad it's
laughable and it's scary but it's also
scary right shouldn't be numb to your
racist rights right i shouldn't be numb
to your behavior
i'm numb to this commentary like
must they run their mouths like that
unfortunately a lot of kids and some
adults
take these ignorant comments seriously
look there might be a cautionary lesson
in lebron for kids
this is what happens when you attempt to
leave high school a year early to join
the nba
and it's always unwise to seek political
advice from someone who gets paid a
hundred million dollars a year
to bounce a ball
oh and lebron and kevin
you're great players but no one voted
for you millions elected trump to be
their coach
so keep the political commentary to
yourself
or as someone once said
shut up and dribble
dave zirin that was yeah that's someone
one year ago yeah and the backlash that
she received was so satisfying from my
perspective because to me this idea of
shut up and dribble i mean you might as
well stay shut up and dance
shut up and sing shut up and entertain
it's telling people that they need to be
less than fully formed human beings who
have thoughts and ideas and opinions
about politics and it's it tries to push
this idea that politics are just for
people who have bad haircuts on capitol
hill and not necessarily something that
we all should have the right uh to be
able to speak on and in many respects i
think what lebron james is talking about
but who by the way has a bigger social
media following than the president uh
what lebron james is talking about
actually connects with millions of
people and athletes historically whether
we're talking about muhammad ali tommy
smith or john carlos billie jean king
they often are able to be our
truth-tellers in society and they're
often able to speak about issues that do
in fact connect with tens of millions of
people and that's why their platform is
policed so assiduously and i view laura
ingram in this regard as a media cop if
you will as a police officer attempting
to make sure that the players shut up
and dribble and what lebron james did
which was so ingenious is he took that
that vile phrase and he turned it into
an entire uh political miniseries that
he produced
where he spoke about the history of
politics in the national basketball
association
so it's brilliant and it's also it shows
that this is very i feel very gratified
about this that we're not the only
people having these kinds of discussions
that these discussions about sports and
politics have now broken out into the
mainstream and i think that's one of the
reasons why people like laura ingram are
so are so panicked when these athletes
do speak out because there's a
recognition of the influence that they
have and you've written also in your
books about uh
the miami heat wearing hoodies well that
to me was like trayvon martin's yeah and
that was with lebron james and dwyane
wade two future hall of famers led that
uh back in i believe it was 2011 when
they did that and that to me was
the game changer when it came to sports
and politics particularly in the
national basketball association because
then you saw other players pose with
hoodies put them on social media and
this is really at the beginning of
twitter as this phenomenon
that people would use and so you saw
them sort of going around the
traditional filters of media
and producing these viral photographs of
players wearing hoodies and the way in
which that influenced discussion
about that particular case and i mean
that that was really remarkable uh what
took place trayvon martin of course was
from florida
and this is an important point there had
already been dozens of walkouts in high
schools in the miami area and around the
trayvon martin case
and that shows to me one of the things
that i think is so important because
oftentimes when athletes are political
we decontextualize it in a way that's
unhelpful
because
the way it works is the protests
invariably start off the field and then
they ricochet onto the field where
athletes respond to them like muhammad
ali for example did not create the
anti-war movement for example but then
these athletes can then influence what
takes place off the field so there's
this incredibly interesting dialectical
boomerang effect from one end to the
other where it's almost like a
conversation between protests off the
field in protest on the field and ways
in which they can serve to grow each
other over the course of this dialogue
why did you choose jim brown as the
topic for your or the subject for your
latest book well because i found the
first of all the issue
of jim brown the person absolutely
fascinating and there's only been one
other biography written about jim brown
which is a terrific book by a writer
named mike freeman came out about a
decade ago but if you look at for
example how many biographies there are
about muhammad ali i mean they fill
pages and pages on your average
bookseller's website
but when you talk about jim brown the
idea that there only been one other
biography and was really stunning to me
because when you when i was looking at
jim brown's life i was looking at
somebody who is arguably the greatest
football player in nfl history was
somebody who made a little disgust
contribution to the black freedom
struggle of the 1960s where he created
these things called the black economic
unions which was an interesting kind of
formation that i felt like hadn't really
been explored there was his experience
in hollywood in the 1970s
where he starred in some of the
blaxploitation era's most uh known or
notorious films there was this effort to
try to
make hollywood uh more racially equal
and balanced in terms of voices behind
the camera and in the production areas
and his inability to do that but his
efforts to do so with richard pryor i
found fascinating uh there's his work
with gangs and in the organization he
started called american
uh which i found at totally fascinating
and then there's um the issue of
violence against women which is
something that's been a part of jim
brown's personal life over the course of
decades and so in looking at all of this
in total
i was like this is a person who has
managed to be relevant and active
over the course of six decades
and then right now he's been in the news
very recently and i was fortunately able
to touch on this in the book before it
was published
his support and interactions with donald
trump
and him trying to be a voice in favor of
donald trump and a voice
uh that inside the white house
and so just
this way in which jim brown is
constantly
restless
and wanting to be not in the public eye
but making
some form of public impact
i found really fascinating and something
that i felt like i really wanted to
write about and tackle
it's a difficult subject because
what i've found is that jim brown you
know is a very polarizing person whether
you're talking about his support of
trump whether you're talking about his
personal life whether you're talking
about uh his work in the 1960s where you
know from doing the research i found he
was very critical of dr martin luther
king and the idea of civil rights
marches and protests just like he's been
very critical in recent years of john
lewis uh the civil rights veteran who's
a member of congress
he refers to civil rights marches as
parades that's something that jim
brown's been doing for 60 years so you
know you're talking about somebody who's
had this very consistent set of politics
over the course of decades that are very
controversial and very polarizing and so
to me that was just an incredibly meaty
subject for a book has american been a
successful organization uh i would argue
it's been very successful um its ability
to actually and jim brown's ability to
leverage his celebrity to actually reach
at-risk youth uh is something that he
should get all the praise in the world
for i mean it's a it's a remarkable set
of work now what i what i try to do in
the book though is have people
understand that
his work for example with donald trump
and his work with the black economic
unions and his work with american they
all they all reflect a kind of
conservative common theme in terms of
where he sees change is coming from
which is not from the government which
is not from struggle which is not from
protest
and i i thought that was so important to
write about because i know a lot of
people who and i write about this in the
book who when he came out in support of
donald trump were like shocked and
appalled they're like this is not my jim
brown jim brown to me is this symbol of
struggle and
and all and things of that nature and
what i try to write in this book is to
say well no actually this is jim brown
and if you look back over the course of
60 years um you'll see that this is
somebody who these have been his
politics over the course of half of the
20th century um this is some video from
trump tower december 13 2016.
it couldn't have been a better meeting
the graciousness the intelligence the
reception we got was fantastic
what are some of the specific policies
you guys talked about
well i think i think
if you talk about what we're trying to
really do from the urban developments
and job creations are everything but i
think you know we're talking about
really what entrepreneurship really
looks like from from the individual
themselves and i think what the american
american icann program has done for so
many years it's put us at that place and
now we have 30 40 000 former gang
members and people who change their
lives but what we believe with the trump
administration is if we can combine
these two powers of coming together
forget black or white black and white is
irrelevant the bottom line is job
creation economic development in these
urban neighborhoods to change the whole
scheme of what of what our kids see for
for our next future and we will drive mr
trump's outreach to african americans
during the campaign
yeah well i think what i do feel is that
he's wide open to really helping us
change what hasn't been changed you know
you talk about you go all the way back
22 trillion dollars since johnson since
president johnson was around and you you
think about what that is of what talking
about like really resolve solving
poverty 22 trillion that we haven't
addressed yet right so for us as a black
community for trump to even step up
there for mr president to step up there
and say i'm gonna do that that means
everything and i think that's why me and
mr brown is here today
and we definitely have a partnership yep
and it's an extension of the outreach
program that we put in place that you
follow so very closely mr trump made a
commitment to improving the conditions
of the lives of african-americans in
this country and this is going to
continue the work that we started during
this campaign with the national
diversity coalition and now with
american jim brown ray lewis and it's a
great combination and the
president-elect was very enthusiastic
about it and committed to doing it
dave zirin there's so much i can say
about that i don't even know where to
begin first and foremost that was in uh
right after the election in 2016 the
first thing i would ask is uh where
where where has the economic development
been where are the urban programs where
are all the things that trump promised
he controlled congress for two years and
so what was his what was his phrase he
said uh what do you have to lose by
voting for me well what's been gotten
since then is a lot of racial
demagoguery uh that we've discussed
sports has been used as a method of that
racial demagoguery through his comments
about the nfl players
which has made what jim brown did going
there and ray lewis the hall of fame
linebacker who was there next to him
seemed like a betrayal to a lot of
people in the nfl and a lot of people in
the sports world particularly when you
have athletes like steph curry lebron
james and colin kaepernick actually
standing up
to donald trump and the trump agenda i
mean i i don't have to go through the
laundry list but when you have a
president who
was called out for uh for unfair housing
practices in the early 1970s fast
forward to what he's done
as president and some of the comments
he's made i mean this has been
a place where racism has festered in
this country over the last couple of
years i mean the growth of white
nationalists and and clan in the streets
of this country i mean it's been a very
difficult time the last couple of years
and so this question to jim brown about
does he feel like the support is worth
it is a question i think
i know how jim brown would answer it he
would say yes it has that's all just
propaganda nonsense what's important is
having the ear of the president i would
disagree with that
did jim brown cooperate in your autobio
in your uh biography
uh it's interesting i was able to go to
his house and stay there for several
days and he was very generous with his
time and i was able to interview him
and so you know that that's what we did
and i was able to interview him it
wasn't the sort of thing where we were
working in conjunction with one another
i was able to speak to him throughout
the writing of the book but i was able
to get several days with him i was able
to sit out on his deck which was amazing
which oversaw
the whole of los angeles um out in the
west hollywood hills and any and it was
it was the sort of thing where jim
brown's a tough guy i mean he is he is a
tough guy and he wasn't going to talk
about anything that he didn't want to
talk about so i was just as a writer
trying to get what i could from him and
most the time what he was talking about
was
trying to just look back on his time in
the world and look forward as to what he
saw coming in the future
what was interesting is like he still
had this kind of restlessness so i
wasn't surprised at all when he came out
for donald trump and was willing to make
himself a lightning rod of controversy
and was willing to criticize john lewis
and was willing to go against
that sort of kaepernick push in the
national football league for social and
racial justice
because he's always sort of looking for
that next fight
and he's not comfortable i mean
keep in mind the the cleveland cavaliers
they won the the world championship in
2016 in the nba and they were the first
team from cleveland to win a
championship since jim brown in 1964. so
when they won in 2016 the cavaliers they
brought jim brown onto the stage they
were like they had jim brown
symbolically pass the trophy to lebron
james if jim brown wanted to he could
sit on his laurels and be lauded and and
all the rest of it and people wouldn't
talk about his experiences with violence
against women and it would be the sort
of thing where you know that people
would say well that's why pencils have
erasers and they wouldn't talk about his
past and he's chosen instead to
align himself with a president who has
his own issues of violence against women
and both of them willing to excuse them
in each other
to create a partnership but i'm not sure
what a partnership is what the
partnership is even for at this point
other than the promotion of
of kanye west
political actor
dave zirin in your book about jim brown
this is a quote
i'm not saying the only reasons i've
gotten in trouble with the police or
that i'm black and outspoken
though if you study american history
those are two damn good reasons yeah
that's uh what jim brown and his
defenders have often said particularly
when his problems with the police not
exclusively but when they have
intersected with the issue of violence
against women it's the idea that
well this is something that's only taken
place because
of being black and outspoken and
i challenge that line of argument in the
book because i think when you do that
you then erase the experiences of the
people who
you know who have come forward and
particularly in this metoo era of people
who are trying to have their truth be
heard and not be drowned out just
because to speak out people will
criticize you for trying to tear
somebody like jim brown down
are you a sports fan and do people enjoy
watching sports with you okay uh that's
a great question one
yes i am a sports fan
and i and two if anybody out there
watching wants to watch sports with me i
promise you you'll have a good time do i
like talking about stuff that's not
necessarily x's and o's when we watch
sports
absolutely do i like doing a little
dissection of the commercials or some of
the politics absolutely do i like saying
stuff like oh that player right there oh
i interviewed him oh he's got some
really interesting things to say about
sub-saharan africa do i like doing that
yeah i like doing that too but for me
that sort of feeds my my enjoyment
because i like looking at the players as
individuals and not merely as you know
as laundry
running up and down a field and you know
i coach my son's basketball team i mean
i'm involved in sports on the level of
more than just this kind of critic
um i like being immersed in it actually
we had a game yesterday where the
dragons in takoma park we did very well
okay now now i'm lost because i didn't
expect that to be the
the last words out of your mouth that
didn't fit into what i was going to say
next my son hit a three-pointer it was
very cool that's fantastic and i
appreciate your helping me get back in
rhythm
how'd you get into this business well i
got into it because i had always been my
dream to do but i never thought it was
possible
and then when i was i was teaching
school in washington dc i was a third
grade teacher in my early 20s
and i was getting ready to get married
and my wife-to-be who i'm still with
very happy to say michelle she said to
me hey you really want to do this sports
writing thing it's now or never buddy
because we're going to start a family
soon and we're going to you know be on
the road to trying to create a life here
so you know this is the time to take
some risks and figure it out and so what
i did was i called every newspaper in
the maryland dc area and said hey i'll
do anything to work there but in return
all i want is a little space to write a
sports column
and then just pay me
you know whatever crud you have left
over and so my first job and it was
actually the sort of thing where um i
made a few hundred dollars a week but i
also had to sell a few hundred dollars a
week in ads
to make my salary
and uh but i was given that space to
write a sports column and it was the the
best education
i could ever have i didn't go to
journalism school i learned how to write
at newspapers
and i'll absolutely i'm absolutely
indebted to everywhere that gave me a
chance so what was the path from that
first job and where was that to being
the nation's sports editor well it that
that was in st mary's county um in
maryland and then i worked for the
princess maryland yes and then i worked
for the prince george's post
uh which is a uh a black owned newspaper
and
and i overheard uh my editor there a man
named augusta floyd speaking to a friend
about politics and it turns out like we
had a lot of shared sort of political
views about the world and i said to him
hey i'd love to make my sports column
more political
and he was very open to it
and once i started writing it in the
prince george's post my brother-in-law
who was really into this newfangled
thing called social media and it was
very newfangled in 2004.
uh he started putting my column out
nationally on these different lists
and once again my brother-in-law jason
janowitz i'm very i'm very indebted to
him
and robert lipsite who is the great
sports writer for the new york times the
great chronicler of muhammad ali he
started reading my stuff and he got in
touch with the nation and said hey i
know you've been thinking of branching
out into sports i think i found your guy
and you've been with the nation ever
since very happily and robert lipscite
he's become a friend and a mentor and i
just have no words for how amazing he is
did you grow up as a sports fan where he
grew up i grew up in new york city i
grew up a huge fan
of the new york mets the new york knicks
the new york football giants and jets
and i got to say like growing up my room
was like people like keith hernandez
huge posters keith hernandez lawrence
taylor dwight gooden i had no idea that
they all had serious cocaine issues but
my room it was like the tony montana
all-stars all around me i was just a
huge fan of of sports and i memorized
every statistic i i would read the back
of baseball cards
i never really thought too much about
the politics of sports until mahmoud
abdul rauf in 1996 made the decision to
not come out for the anthem and i was
able to interview mahmoud abdullah with
a couple of years ago about kaepernick
and i was able to say to him you should
know
that you changed the entire course of my
life by doing what you did
and he was so gracious and so humble and
it was really remarkable and it was also
so cool to interview him because even
though i'd been trying to interview him
for 15 years because of the influence he
had on my life and his political stance
and he never really wanted to do an
interview and then after colin
kaepernick started to make his stance it
made him mahmood more confident to speak
out about his own experience and that's
how i was able to speak to him
and i'll never forget what he said to me
he said
a setback is nothing but a set up for a
comeback
yeah when i met pete rose i uh was able
to recite the entire 7172 cincinnati
reds lineup to him i bet he loved that
but
no because he was watching horse racing
oh
oh because i was just another you know
guy coming up yeah guy coming up to him
while he was
watching horse racing see i i found i've
never i only started i interviewed i've
interviewed pete rose before and found
him to be
almost disturbingly gregarious like he
wanted to talk about everything and so i
had this view of him as somebody who
because he's shut out of the sport any
opportunity to talk about it his
he's beyond effusive
let's take some calls let's hear from
glenn freeland michigan glenn you're on
with author and sports writer dave siren
oh
thank you all very much um
and um i like the uh al pacino scarface
reference there
what i didn't like so much was um i'm a
trump voter i'm not a blind supporter
though but about trump and the black
community under trump we have the lowest
black unemployment rate
ever in u.s history now
trump just signed that criminal justice
reform bill that was applauded by people
like van jones the black environmental
activist from the obama administration
he's pardoned black felons that obama
never did
and as far as his history on race jesse
jackson and people like that applauded
him for all he did for the black
community for years and years before he
became
a republican all right glenn we got the
point dave zirin yeah a couple of things
i mean first and foremost what i was
talking about specifically were programs
aimed at urban america that we have not
seen infrastructure projects uh the like
of it and there were tremendous promises
that were put forward to make that a
reality the low unemployment is a pro is
a product of an economic expansion
that's been ongoing for
for years honestly
that's the first thing i mean the second
thing is when we talk about criminal
justice and criminal justice reform this
isn't about doing a compare and contrast
with president obama this is about
thousands of people at the grassroots
level who've been fighting for criminal
justice reform for years and years and
years and put extraordinary pressure on
the federal government to finally do
something about prison expansion three
strikes and your outlaws and the like
so i think it's important once again to
contextualize the climate in which these
things have taken place and lastly
i think jesse jackson would take issue
with the idea that for years he
supported donald trump as a friend to
the african-american community i mean
that there there also there are these
awards that that trump won
uh in the 1980s that that are often
trumpeted that that i mean people should
look at the twitter feed of kevin cruz
krusc and what he does is he unwraps and
discusses exactly where those awards
come from and why and they're not
necessarily awards that have to do with
uh racial justice or racial
reconciliation by any stretch of the
imagination
emily boulder colorado hi emily
um i'm not a sports fan but i found out
from an excellent documentary about
larry dobby that he was the second
person to break the color lines in
baseball why isn't he mentioned more
often he should be mentioned more often
thank you so much for that question and
big shout out to boulder colorado which
i love um larry dobie he integrated the
american league with the chicago white
sox the owner of the white sox bill vac
as in wreck as he would call himself
larry dobby was an absolute trailblazer
he only he came onto the scene an
incredibly short amount of time after
jackie robinson i mean i think the fact
that jackie robinson had so much
success with the dodgers winning the
first rookie of the year award and then
mvp the following year and just the uh
the dramatic arc of what jackie robinson
went through uh playing for the brooklyn
dodgers in that huge new york market has
obscured larry dobby uh we really
shouldn't we need larry dobby books we
need larry adobe films we need larry
dobby education because his story in and
of itself is one that deserves to be um
held aloft
and you write very extensively about
jackie robinson his testimony in front
of the uh house on american activities
committee
was branch rickey a hero or was branch
rickey
it was branch rickey a hero in europe
it's not dissimilar to what we were
talking about earlier with regards to
nike in that branch ricky saw
a money-making opportunity with the idea
of integrating major league baseball he
saw it and he also saw the country as
having made a big shift uh with regards
to world war ii uh with the regards of
of the the number of african-american
soldiers who fought and then returned
home the desegregation of the army by
harry s truman all of these things
were coming together and branch rickey
very candidly saw it as the moment to
integrate major league baseball it also
didn't hurt that kennesaw mountain
landis the commissioner of major league
baseball who upheld the quote-unquote
gentleman's agreement to keep the league
white that he passed away and there was
a new commissioner named happy chandler
who said if someone is good enough to
fight
for the united states they're good
enough to play baseball so branch ricky
saw all of these factors coming together
and then he started to look for a type
and people don't realize this people
should know that there are a lot of
people in the black community who were
not happy that jackie robinson was the
choice to integrate major league
baseball they thought it should be
someone like josh gibson or satchel page
one of the people who held the negro
leagues aloft
who kept them together during this long
period of time and jackie robinson was
seen as this hot head who came out of
ucla but
but he was also a veteran and branch
ricky was looking for a type and he
found that type
in jack roosevelt robinson
tweet this is from sandra as a lifelong
sports fan i had heroes growing up now
with social media we find out all the
things we disagree with but never knew
do you have to put on blinders to be a
fan these days no i don't think you have
to put on blinders actually i think the
opposite i think we need to take the
blinders off and be conscious sports
fans and i think we'll be better sports
fans for it it's important to really
look at what we like and what we don't
like about sports and what we like and
don't like about the individuals who
play sports so we can challenge it to
change so we can challenge sports to be
better there's nothing wrong with doing
that it's something that we've
historically
asked of other
cultural parts of our society whether
you're talking about music or film
and you see these questions coming up a
great deal now with the metoo movement
with regards to hollywood
we're demanding more and i don't think
there's anything wrong with doing that
particularly when you factor in the fact
these athletes are role models i mean we
can talk about how how much better it
would be if firefighters or teachers
were role models but the you know but
it's one of those things where it's just
an objective fact it's like the the old
expression you don't have to believe in
gravity to fall out of an airplane you
don't have to believe that sports
athletes should be role models but they
are role models and so we should ask the
question about what in fact they are
modeling
portion of dave zirin's a recent column
from the nation whom to root for at any
super bowl is usually an easy choice it
is insert your favorite team here or
whoever is playing against the new
england patriots yet this year it is
tougher than most to find a team to
cheer for
because the patriots are playing the la
rams yes
i mentioned this earlier i have a very
tough time rooting for the new england
patriots and let me say this before the
entire weight of massachusetts new
hampshire maine and rhode island uh and
half of connecticut because you know
that's border country before that falls
on my shoulders let me say is it's
difficult to not have an incredible
amount of respect for what the new
england patriots have done they made 13
afc championship games in 17 years and
this is a league that is built to create
parity it's a league that's brilliantly
constructed through salary constraints
um
and scheduling so a team that was
terrible one year could be great the
next year so every you go unlike with
baseball i would argue you go into every
season with hope that you have a super
bowl contender in your hometown unless
of course you live in washington um and
yeah sorry i had to throw that in there
somehow dan snyder has managed to beat
the parody rules in washington and
somehow bill belichick and robert kraft
and tom brady the quarterback uh they
have been able to defeat the rules of
parity and make these 13 afc
championship games in 17 years this is
going to be their ninth super bowl today
brady's either going to go six and three
or five and four but either way going to
nine super bowls in an nfl career when
just going to one is an incredible
career accomplishment i mean it is
remarkable that being said i'm from new
york city and i can't get over the fact
that they are a massachusetts team and
their success absolutely torments and
tortures me so that i that's where i am
with the new england patriots i mean
other people will say things like oh
they they cheated they deflated the
balls they were spy gate they were
filming opposing teams that to me i
don't take too seriously i mean partly
because i think every team in the nfl is
and this is my experience and i could
talk about it more off the air but i
know of a lot of teams that have looked
for edges
in all kinds of interesting ways
when you play in the national football
league it's i mean these are the most
competitive people on earth or in that
top one percent of competitive people
and so ever the patriots did or didn't
do all i would say is they did it better
than other teams
to get ahead and
the la rams are very tough for me to
root for
uh because the way that they left st
louis
was it was very difficult thing to
swallow there are currently four
lawsuits taking place against the team
for how they left the city the city is
going to be paying for the stadium
in st louis until i believe 2021
the city offered them 500 million
dollars in public money which was turned
down by the owner of the team stan
cranky
and the thing about stan crunky is that
his given name is enos stanley cranky he
was named after enos slaughter and stan
musial the two greatest stars in the
history of the st louis cardinals
because he was born in columbia missouri
and so the idea that this son of st
louis named after the great cardinals
would abuse the city in such a way and
go for greener pastures in california
well you know my dad's from brooklyn and
you know it just it summoned up all
these memories of stories i heard
growing up about the way the dodgers
left for los angeles and the old jokes
about walter o'malley the owner of the
dodgers that are
a little off color perhaps for for
c-span but enough of them were told that
i you know i knew growing up that uh
that abandoning your hometown for l.a
was is the act of is a traitorous act uh
in the sports landscape so very
difficult to root for the rams very
difficult to root for the patriots i'm
going to root for good commercials
and for uh food but those of us old
enough to remember it was the l.a rams
long before it was the saint louis round
yes and it was the cleveland rams before
that so it starts in cleveland
they leave for la
they
but they had been in st louis um for
a good 20 years yeah 22 years and in
that time they'd won a super bowl they'd
been to two super bowls i mean they'd
certainly you know made a home for
themselves in st louis and it also it
hurts because st louis is a really
serious and intense sports town and in
los angeles i mean there have been a lot
of news reports about this people are
only barely aware that their team is in
the super bowl i mean there's just a lot
to do in los angeles and los angeles is
a place that for years until the rams
and then the chargers came just in the
last couple of years from san diego to
la they didn't have a team the second
largest media market in the country the
world's i mean not the world's the
country's most popular sport did not
have a team in los angeles and now they
have two
and there's no evidence that people have
necessarily noticed
dave zirin why did you say we'd have to
talk off air about some of the edges
that these one percent top one percent
of athletes have taken to win well
because i think that when you're talking
to these teams i mean whether you're
talking about the medicine that they
shoot themselves up with
so they can get out onto the field the
sacrifices that are made to their
physical bodies so they could get out
there on the field
and what teams do to actually find out
what other teams are doing
so they can prepare the proper game
plans i mean there's a reason why the
coaches when you see them on television
they're always talking to each other
with the the clipboard over their faces
because they're scared of lip readers
and so it's not just this paranoia it
doesn't just exist in a vacuum it exists
because there is this great deal of of
competitiveness and willingness to win
at all costs and this uh vince lombardi
ethos even though a lot of the quotes
attributed to lombardi we're not sure if
he actually said but this idea of you
know winning isn't everything it's the
only thing and this
um you know this ethos that says that
the the ends has to just can justify any
means when it comes to winning a
football game which also relating to
something we talked about before isn't
necessarily the healthiest thing to
model
is there ever
a good reason for a city to
build a stadium for a private
sports owner you know i've debated this
a great deal with folks and
i think we've moved beyond the point
where it's a question of opinion because
we have so much data it's like now we're
at the point where it's debating whether
or not the sky is blue
because we have so much data at this
point and there have been so many
studies at this point that show that
building a stadium with public money is
just not an effective use of public
money i mean one of the most famous
quotes about it is that uh you're better
off dropping a billion dollars from an
airplane and just letting it land in the
streets and having people pick and pick
them up and and use them in stores that
that is a better use of a billion
dollars in public money than actually
building a stadium and it makes sense
when you really think about it because
you got to think about say an nfl
stadium how many days a year is it open
i mean unless you're talking about
playoff games you know eight games a
year maybe you have a couple concerts in
there or other events during the year
but what happens to the neighborhoods
around the stadium
when there aren't games all the various
bars and restaurants i mean it's like
they're like ghost towns for goodness
sakes i mean people should do that
sometimes is go to the neighborhood
of your nfl stadium
when there is not a game day
and just walk around
and see what the atmosphere around it is
like i mean there might as well be big
bales of hay
slowly floating through the streets
this is this is where this is where we
are and the jobs that are created tend
to be non-union low-income and seasonal
work
and so there are bet there are just
better ways to spend money and then
there's just the basic moral fact of
that you're giving um a billionaire
a billion dollars and 500 million to a
billion dollars of public money uh to
build a stadium instead of them building
their own stadium
next call for dave zirin comes from
margaret in fayetteville arkansas hi
margaret oh hey margaret
hello good morning good afternoon i'm
margaret
i have a comment and a question
my comment is uh football causes brain
injury similar to boxing
and football and boxing are forms of
human sacrifice
despite these facts tax treasure is
lavished on football in junior high and
high school and college the coaches make
a living and frequently get very rich
off the sacrifices of their players the
players get very little frequently
nothing
beginning in sixth grade boys come to
believe
they will become rich pro football
players so these boys begin neglecting
their academic studies in order to
devote more time to football they get
very far behind in their academics and
the truth is it's more likely and easier
for a boy to become a doctor than a
professional football player partly
because of the limited number of job
openings in professional football all
right margaret let's get a response to
those statements from dave zirin i have
to say first and foremost
the sea change in how people look at
football
in terms of the physical toll it takes
on players can be seen in the fact that
that was a call from margaret from
fayetteville arkansas fayetteville yeah
of the university of arkansas yes yes
and and also
southeastern conference country i mean
this is where football is oftentimes at
its most intense and we hear from
margaret and margaret i think is the
voice of a growing chorus of people who
are starting to ask this question
about whether football is something
that will exist into the next generation
or two and football for all of its
economic success as we talked about at
the start of the show it's also
something that operates currently with
this great existential fear
that it may go the way of boxing the way
boxing used to be the number one sport
in the united states and people still
get up for a big fight but it's less and
less this kind of cultural phenomenon
that people revolve around and people
know the rankings and people discuss it
over the water cooler
football has changed
and it's changing because science is not
football's friend so the more we learn
the more scientific fact we get i mean
the fact that you had you know we'll
have donald trump today on television
talking about how he doesn't want his
son to play football when he criticized
the nfl for being too soft and
criticized president obama for saying
something similar i mean these are
important data points that we should
keep track of as the cultural wheel
turns
james reston the great journalist he
once said that
people in the press the media is much
better at covering revolution than
evolution
and i think that's very true there is no
revolution against football taking place
but there is an evolution
tony tweet
a lot of the discussion so far has
focused on male athletes yes can dave
speak more about women athletes in the
way that their contributions are often
marginalized when we talk about politics
and sports great question tony and i i
write a great deal toni by the way okay
great question tony toni i write a great
deal about female athletes um and both
historically and in the present
and i think what what you see with with
women athletes i think there's this
really interesting historical continuum
uh where it's a social question
oftentimes the role and placement of
female athletes in the broader society
and so when women athlete when women in
general
are a part of social movements for
women's rights in a particular decade
you see the elevation of women athletes
and when those same athletes are pushed
backwards then you see sports push
backwards as well i mean you see that in
the 1920s where you have the emergence
of
of post-suffragette movements and you
also see the fact that some of the most
celebrated athletes in the country were
women in the 1920s swimmers like
gertrude ederle
athletes like mildred babe didrikson
this was a different kind of era in the
1920s you saw women in the 1940s when
they were entering the factories
and how they were able to also start the
all-american professional girls baseball
league and then in the 1950s you saw the
way women were pushed off of the field
with the backlash against women
generally in the 1950s and then you
can't separate the women's liberation
movement
in the late 60s and 70s without speaking
about the rise of people like billie
jean king
and i would also put wyomiatius the
greats track star of the 1960s who was
one of the founding members of the
women's sports foundation an absolute
legend who gets forgotten uh but it's so
important for us to know this know this
history i mentioned rose robinson
earlier uh the woman who did not stand
for the anthem in 1959 people don't
speak about rose robinson well some
people do there's a terrific scholar out
penn state amira davis who's done
terrific work on this but when you talk
about the general sports oxygen
it's not discussed in the way it should
be and
uh and this needs to change and i think
today
um as you've seen a lot of athletes
particularly the incredibly heroic women
with usa gymnastics
who've come forward and influenced by
the metoo movement to speak out against
sexual abuse um in usa gymnastics i mean
you see the way you can't separate what
happens off the field with what happens
on the field
and the tremendous athletic
accomplishments usually accompany
accomplishments and a push forward for
women's rights in general and dave zirin
in a people's history you write
rather extensively about a woman named
althea gibson oh absolutely right about
althea gibson and um what makes our
theme
great the great tennis player althea
gibson 50s 1950s yep um
and really a trailblazer in every regard
in the sport and somebody recognized by
serena and venus williams of course as
the great african-american trailblazer
that she was althea gibson uh what makes
her also very interesting is that she's
somebody who
uh believed unlike jackie robinson that
her play itself
was a political statement like jackie
robinson believed and she would often
speak about jackie robinson in sort of
like a compare and contrast mode because
she was referred to as the jackie
robinson of her sport
and but she believed that
her play
could do the talking for her and the
mere fact in this very restricted uh
lilly white world of tennis and her
succeeding that in and of itself is a
political statement and that had a lot
of influence on my thinking when i read
some about thea gibson's thoughts about
that because it made me realize that you
really have
these two kinds of political athletes
you have the ones who are
extremely like representative
um just the mere fact that they're on
the field is a political act and then
you have the ones who are explicit the
ones who then use their platform to
speak out about politics and in althea
gibson you have one of the great
representative athletes who ever lived
and someone like jackie robinson you
have someone who is both representative
and explicit in terms of him
being willing to speak out about
politics particularly after his
retirement
as well as somebody who when he took the
field it made a profound political
statement
from game over growing up in new york
city i was a mets fan down to the marrow
of my bones sure was that's why for
countless fans and me
this story has been painful like no
other the ugly truth has been unveiled
the mets weren't my team or new york
city's team
i mean the mets have been in
financial problems for years and which
is just bizarre being a new york team
that plays in a publicly funded stadium
named after a bank
uh playing in citi field as they are
citi
and yet the owners of the team though
the will ponds
they
had a ton of money from them stolen by
bernie madoff and
it's made the the running of the team on
a on a week-to-week basis incredibly
difficult
uh
and on a year-to-year basis and even
when they've been able to develop
incredible talent like they have in
recent years that talent finds itself
eventually sold by the pound
so yeah that's been that's been a very
difficult uh
process to try to remain a mets fan in
the context of a team that you feel like
used public money the money that went to
build city field and the profits from
that then invested with bernie madoff
and then
uh dissipated
uh so you don't you never like the idea
of your team being used as a kind of
money laundering operation
that's about particularly public money
it makes it difficult to then root for
the team and this is where i think maybe
it relates to what we were talking about
earlier about is it difficult to be a
sports fan in this climate uh because
sometimes it is difficult when you learn
about the way a team actually runs when
you see how the sausage is made if you
will to actually root and it's i think
it's so important uh to focus on the art
of the play
because there is art in sports and there
is something beautiful about seeing
athletes male female what have you out
there on the field i mean i get so much
out of watching maya moore diana taurasi
i'm a big wnba fan and i love going to
those games
because one of the things it reminds me
of is why i fell in love with sports in
the first place all right title nine has
that been a success
you know 20 000 people will attend a
male
basketball game in the ncaa
1700 will attend to women's but the
parity the money is there for both right
well it depends on where you go i mean
you go to uconn uconn it'll sell out
you'll sell out and have a good time um
in a rabid environment um title ix been
a profound success it's difficult to
even
come up with pieces of legislation that
exceed title ix in terms of the actual
impact it's had
on the number of people that it's had
the impact on signed into law by richard
nixon
and that in and of itself i think is a
lesson unto itself
because it showed the way that public
pressure and movements are the context
in which title ix was able to become law
and a lot of i'm sure folks know this
but
but if they don't they should know that
title ix language doesn't even say
anything about sports um what it's about
is equal opportunity and equal funding
in places that receive government
funding and that there needs to be equal
opportunity for men and women but it's
just in the sports world where it's had
the most incredible effect
the last statistics i saw is that
roughly one out of three young girls
play sports and before title ix that
number was i believe one out of 29. and
young girls who play sports i mean
there's so many positive things that
come out of that whether you're talking
about socially
whether you're talking about mental
health
whether you're talking about their their
physical health and these opportunities
would not be there without title ix and
just when you think of the tens of
millions
of young women that it's affected and i
think it's also changed the way
young men see women as well and i think
that's really important because when we
talk about fighting sexism that first
and foremost is not a discussion of
course with women that's a discussion
with men
and sports is oftentimes the way is the
yardstick in our society for how we
understand the question of equality and
it has been since the foundation of
organized sports that's why i talked
before about women's sports being a
social question
when you think about
the ways in which sports started it was
started with this mythology of the level
playing field yet women and many people
of color were denied a place on that
playing field and so anytime you had a
push to actually find a space on that
field it both exposed the playing field
as not being level and
it pushed to make it even more level in
a morality play that was public for the
for the world and the public to see
williams in fredericksburg virginia
you're on with author dave zirin
certainly appreciate c-span it's a
terrific resource for all of us
last season i became
transfixed
by le'veon bell the running back
for the pittsburgh steelers
absolute houdini
on the field do you have any insight
or information as to why he did not
report this year there seems to be an
issue or issues there that
they go beyond
his mere personal con contract
yeah
i think this so connects with the
discussion we were having before about
what we know about physical health and
football players
le'veon bell is a running back for folks
who don't know what the pittsburgh
steelers he's equally adept catching the
ball out of the backfield as he is
running
and le'veon bell he made the decision to
just not report this year and he'll be a
free agent going into this off season
and he turned a lot of money down i
believe just under nine hundred thousand
dollars a week
uh because he believes that he is going
to get more money on the free agent
market coming out of this year and he
did not want to risk getting hurt this
year that kind of business decision is
something that's been unheard of in the
nfl up to now but what i'm finding out
both when i talk to players and in
articles i read is that there is so much
more
savviness right now and the willingness
to resist public and organizational
pressure
because people feel like well this is my
one shot this is when i'm going to make
99 of the money that i'm going to make
in my entire life and the average career
is only three and a half years
so he made a business decision to sit
out a year and test free agency and
we're going to find out whether or not
that was an intelligent one or not i
mean one thing's for sure is
if no other team will the new york jets
are always willing to spend a lot of
money for somebody whether they have the
ability to play or not so there's always
the jets
2009 sports illustrated article
estimated that 75
of football players out of the league
and 60
of nba players now out of the league are
either bankrupt or in financial
disrepair you know and that those
numbers don't surprise me because
there's so little financial education
it's actually gotten a lot better
because now they do it with the rookie
what are called the rtps the rookie
transitional programs where the rookies
come into the league and they get they
that people speak to them um who are
financial experts who speak to them
about how to put money aside who speak
to them about the importance of saving
and but but for a lot of players that
that kind of financial literacy doesn't
exist and you know for myself you know
at 19 20 21 and folks should ask
themselves what was your level of
financial literacy at that age and would
it have made a difference if you had a
hundred dollars or a million dollars i
mean i mean i got in trouble in college
for bouncing checks when i was writing
four dollar checks to buy sub sandwiches
at the terrific place across the street
from mcalester college and i didn't even
realize i was writing checks that were
beyond my account number i mean if i was
doing that with four dollars i would
have done that with four hundred
thousand dollars and it would be a car
instead of a sub
uh and some sandwich to be clear and so
so it doesn't surprise me i think the
leagues and the unions have taken
important steps to make sure that number
goes down in the future but it is pretty
harrowing when you um when you meet
players and i and i've met players
particularly at these rookie
transitional programs who come in like
these players who are heroes they they
come and they say like hey you've all
heard of me you saw my all-star games i
now have no money
and they just get in front of them and
tell them their stories and you can hear
a pin drop in the room when they do that
so what do you think about
one and done in the ncaa and i i guess
i'm thinking of these athletes who
started young
seventh eighth grade and they were
targeted
by
teams or by sports and
their whole lives have been just about
themselves and just about their
three-pointer their their ability to run
through a line and all of a sudden
they're
it but it's always been about them okay
i'm done
yeah it's it's amazing like the the
amount of blinders one has to have first
of all to to even just go to that level
but then the one and done program one of
the things that exposes is the ways in
which our institutions of higher
learning are just the minor leagues
uh for the national basketball
association and so i think we have to
take a step back and ask ourselves
do we approve of that as a starting
point so i don't think there should be a
one and done rule i think if you're 18
years old and you know if that means
you're old enough to fight in a war it
means you're old enough to drive a car
if you're old enough to do these things
then you should be old enough to get a
job and play in the national basketball
association now what the nba wants is
for these players to play a year and
brand themselves
to both the college and to the audience
so there's more excitement when they
come into the league
and they're more developed physically
and mentally they think to play in the
league uh but as a rule it doesn't seem
very just or or
very even constitutional if you think
about it i mean this idea that we're not
we're going to constrain your ability to
make a living
uh because of
the situ the the fix we have in with the
ncaa
next call is joseph astoria new york go
ahead joseph
yes hello yes uh
and i'm a
fan of the mets too i i saw the mets at
the
giant stadium the mets of the home team
playing against the giants but anyway
and i and i used to play for bryan high
school right there i i was the the last
year where where i was old whites right
and i had a friend of mine did this guy
lamont wolf
and he he was just he was he had such a
high iq in the game i had iq
high iq because they just made it as a
freshman but here's the thing
do do you know you know
you're in politics too right every game
has these rules you have to follow the
rules
with the witness with democracy
you have to follow the rules but
for some reason
you know i i'm not a harvard graduate of
some
but these people you know i i have a
hundred times more than i would ever
need
but
look
i i'm helping 89 people right but
you know what do do you know the the
there was this this the captain of my
basketball team was uh bobby brill right
he
i felt like i was part of him so i was
working downtown he was a
hey
i apologize we're getting a little off
track there but i'm not sure where he
was going but i'd love to have a beer
with joseph from the story
i think he sounds like he's got some
amazing stories
uh and he said one thing that i that i
really want to pull out of that which is
i think one of the reasons why we are so
attracted to sports is because there are
supposed to be rules they're supposed to
be rules in politics they're supposed to
be rules in society
but oftentimes we see those rules get
flaunted
flagrantly and nobody have to pay a
price for that and at least in sports
between the lines there are set of rules
that make sense it's why cheating makes
people so upset in the world of sports
it's why steroids and baseball made
people so upset it's why the idea of
pete rose betting against his own
pitchers and games uh made people so
upset the idea of tom brady deflating
football has made people so upset it's
because you want to feel that at the
very least this could be one space where
rules are respected and everything is
above board and on the level
richard haverhill massachusetts good
afternoon
good afternoon hi david
david i know so many people that like uh
donald trump and rob kraft is one who
considers him a friend well just
recently he had an interview on fox news
and he was quoted as saying what he's
working trump is working very hard to
serve the best interests of the country
and he went on to place
murdoch as one of the most outstanding
human beings on the planet so my
question is is that these uh
these
interviewers never follow up or what is
it about and that you think he's doing
so well and showing the best interest of
the country taking little children away
from their parents and put him in cages
uh and
defending the white nationalist
march down in charlottesville virginia
uh uh yelling and screaming the jews
would not own us yeah so um
you know and also before i forget uh
that dave played it off i don't you
probably saw that jackie robinson uh the
42 of the 100
in the new york times recently i thought
that was a great supplement showing
jackie from the beginning to his whole
life more or less i'm sure you saw it i
did all right richard wonderful it was
absolutely wonderful i mean i think what
you mentioned at the start is just
something we have to keep in mind is
that as much as pro sports owners and
you mentioned bob kraft
like to brand themselves with their team
um you know these teams were ours before
it was ever there so if you love the
patriots it doesn't mean you have to
love bob craft and it also means we can
be critical of bob craft because i think
you're right that would have been a tour
i mean shocking that this didn't happen
on fox and friends but it would have
been a great follow-up question to ask
well in what ways do you think the
president is working in the best
interests of our country can you give us
some concrete examples
i think he would be as flummoxed as as i
would be if asked a similar question
you say the teams belong to us not the
owners is there an owner out there that
you
think has done a good job i love the
owner of the green bay packers because
there are hundreds several hundred
thousand of them and how is how does
that work well they're a community-owned
team what you do is you you buy shares
and all you get for buying shares in the
packers is i think you get it you do get
a piece of paper that says that you are
a shareholder in the green bay packers
you get no dividends you get no stock
from it you just get the satisfaction
that you that you are um somebody who
owns a piece of this team and by owning
a piece of that team one of the things
you're guaranteeing is two things which
i think are very important the first is
that they're not going to move unlike
the cleveland slash los angeles st louis
los angeles rams for example
but but you get more than that you also
know that
publicly
the public till isn't going to get hosed
for us things like stadium improvements
or roads because what they do is they
just sell more stock and then more
people get to own pieces of the team so
it's almost like this act of of
community solidarity to keep the packers
in green bay
and this is something that by the way
it's written into the nfl bylaws that no
other team is allowed to be owned in
this way it's something that was
grandfathered in from from way back when
the nfl was this rinky dink small
operation and they were trying to think
of a way to keep the team in green bay
but dave siren there has to be a they
that make sure that the team's buses
show up on time and and manage everyday
affairs and make decisions for the team
who are the they
well in there yeah the they is the vast
apparatus that runs a team but that they
also exist in green bay
there is an apparatus at the top there
is an executive group that makes these
kinds of decisions
and i think certainly there are greater
and lesser evil of owners that are out
there i just i like to look to the ones
that use their own money to spend for
stadiums and don't rely on public funds
that to me makes a good owner the other
thing that makes a good owner to me
unlike say jerry jones with the dallas
cowboys is somebody who doesn't think
just because they own the team they
somehow have some unique insight into
what makes a good team
and they actually hire experts to do
their job and then they just leave them
alone which is something to bob kraft's
credit he has done this is bill
belichick's team
and bill belichick has shown himself to
be
a master at operating an nfl football
team but if jerry jones was the owner of
the new england patriots i bet bill
belichick would have lasted three four
years
not unlike jimmy johnson who is another
incredible thinker about football who
only lasted a few years was able to win
two super bowls and then him and jerry
jones went kaputski
gillette stadium city field fedex field
wrigley field in chicago what do you
think about the corporation or the
corporateness of naming stadiums and and
uh and getting advertising inside these
i mean it's something that's happened
with soccer for for years and years but
it's even in nba they're wearing
just thinking that they now wear the
logos on the ge on the boston
team on the celtics yeah i mean this
isn't anything new i mean but just you
know back in the day when people would
go to brooklyn dodgers games it would
say ball hits here win a free suit you
know at harry's you know so
there was oh there's always been
advertising in the stadiums it's just
there's there's a recognition about how
it's become big business and you know
corporate naming rights are something
that you know are just a part of free
advertising so when you talk about
american airlines arena you're talking
about american airlines arena
the i think one of the things about it
is that in most of these stadium
contracts uh that money goes directly
into ownership like the selling of those
naming rights and that's something
that's always been
bothersome to me when you consider how
much public money goes into
funding the stadiums let the public have
that money as well for first roads
schools libraries what have you let's
hear from ethan in tempe arizona hi
ethan
ethan
ethan you with us
not there let's hear from stephen
stoneham massachusetts oh boy stephen
hey guys great show thank you so many
questions
but uh i've got to say in the 60s uh
when i was a teenager i was a huge fan
baseball fan of the white stocks
and cubs one of those rare
you know persons had rooted for both
teams but
i looked at baseball players almost like
god like
and
then in the late 60s this guy came out
with a book called ball four oh wow
and uh read that and instead of turning
me off from the sport it actually
made me see the players and and the
teams you know more realistic view and i
just wondered your take on that i love
this call so much and i'll tell you why
um because he's talking about uh steve
from stoneham is talking about ball four
which was written by jim bowden
uh in 1960 about the 1969 season that he
spent with a team that no longer exists
the seattle pilots
and when
jim bowden wrote this book it was the
ultimate violation of what we talked
about at the top of the show about the
rule of the jockocracy that sports and
politics don't mix because what jim
bowden did
which was an incredibly political act is
he ripped away the curtain and talked
about like what players do when they're
bored and when players drink and how
players meet women on the road all of
these things which you know you read the
book now and it's almost quaint in terms
of what the players did and how they
live their lives
it's almost it's sweet when you read it
now like a sweet look at a bygone era
but at the time i mean jim bouten found
himself
like harassed out of the sport our
friend pete rose we spoke about earlier
uh was famously got up on the dugout and
cursed him out and
derisively called him shakespeare which
i guess was a big insult for pete rose
um and the i i i truly love this book
like if someone asked me like can you
read uh five books about like written by
athletes i mean ball four by jim bowden
is at the top of the list as a classic
and the ones that he wrote after that
like ball five
ball six which were just like because
you get so into his life and his family
that he would do updates about them
and i don't know if the baton family is
watching right now but um i've done a
couple events with jim bowden over the
years and i mean just just a terrific
human being
next call jerry's in cherry valley
illinois you're on with author dave
zirin hi
hi dave hi i want to piggyback on the
last call because i was a big white fox
fan too
and i remember when
minnie minoso had to take a street car
from the south side
to play ball with the white sox at
comiskey park and then i have a
correction and a question yes go ahead
please jerry we're listening hey
okay
i know you're very knowledgeable dave
but
larry dolby came in with the cleveland
indian oh i'm sorry
yeah i just i switched it off i'm sorry
that was my fault i know you i just
misspoke apologies okay
yeah the only reason i bring it up is
it's so important it is so important
that was literally a case of my i
absolutely knows with the cleveland
indians i'm very red-faced right now
yeah okay
my question is i'm a big hockey fan and
i see in the nhl maybe
one
person on the team of african-american
descent or none what's going on
washington capitals yeah i mean there's
a history of a lot of exclusion and
racism in hockey which which needs to be
addressed um
they're
i mean it's one of the things we know
about sports is that when young people
have access they play
and so it becomes a question of access
and it becomes a question of player
development and it becomes a question of
reaching out
and not having this uh this exclusionary
kind of system and
um i i appreciate the caller very much
uh for bringing that up
and my goodness i did say larry dobby
played for the white side what what a
ridiculous error on my part apologize
that's what we call an unforced error
well i'm glad he was there listening and
yes and and knew that right away
so well you talk about some of your
favorite books we always ask the authors
who appear on this program what some of
their favorite books are and the top of
the list is redemption song muhammad ali
in the spirit of the 1960s oh by mike
marcusy i mean this was a book i
mentioned before about when mahmoud
abdul rauf made his stance in 1996 it
made me want to explore the intersection
of sports and politics but it was
redemption song that made me want to
become a sports writer
mike markussy writes about the political
history of muhammad ali in a way that
has so much
rhythm and nuance and excitement
that i'm reading this and i'm thinking
to myself why can't sportswriting be
like this why can't it be political why
can't it talk about
what what is being said
off the field or outside the ring and
then how that influenced what happened
inside the ring and so it's just the way
mike marcusy told that story
made me want to become a sports writer
and i recommend it to people all the
time if they say to me what's one sports
book
i should read
i i always say this i say well don't
read mine
read redemption song by mike marcusy the
other three books that you sent in to us
are not sports books no song of solomon
american tabloid fear and loathing on
the campaign trail hunter s thompson
yeah i mean let's start at the bottom
there i mean fear and loathing on the
campaign trail by hunter s thompson that
was a book that
a friend of mine said to me when i said
i wanted to go into journalism he said
read this book and then read it twice
and give you an idea of what what
journalism should look like and what
should sound like and so fear and
loathing on the campaign trail had this
great impact on me because i was reading
it it's so fun when you read something
with with this greater purpose in mind
when you say to yourself i'm going to
try to figure out uh not just not just
be entertained or not just be a consumer
of what i'm reading but actually the art
of how it's being written and that's how
i read that book and it affected me
very strongly um
in reverse american tabloid by james
elroy i'm just a sucker for those kinds
of books i love pot boilers i love
historical fiction um give me give me
american tabloid i think i've read it
three times and then song of solomon by
toni morrison i mean she's just the
greatest
fiction writer to ever walk the earth
and i think nobody does
the final line of a book or the final
paragraph of a book better than tony
morrison and it keeps me reading all her
books
um and then recommending them to others
and when other people say something like
oh i'm having a little trouble getting
through beloved or i'm having a little
trouble getting through the bluest eye
i'm always i always say to them
keep reading
because that last paragraph will knock
you on your behind
currently reading football for a buck
the crazy rise and crazier demise of the
usfl jeff pearlman yeah by jeff perlman
jeff prominent wrote a terrific book
about the mets my mets from the 1980s
called i believe it was called uh the
bad guys won um i hope i got that title
right and so every time jeff perlman
writes a book i i'm really into it
because he he's
he's an interesting writer in that he
writes with a kind of verve and
excitement with that i think bring the
sports alive and this i grew up actually
a fan of the usfl i loved this
this rag tag
football league that was playing in the
spring with
cool team names and and you know the
memphis showboats and the pittsburgh
maulers i mean this was
the new jersey generals the and this was
a lot of fun for me did president trump
have a hand in all this yeah and that's
a big part of the story is that
president trump basically brought this
league down i mean it was a very popular
league trump was the owner of the new
jersey generals
and it was president trump who as the
book outlines really cajoled the league
to try to move from being spring
football
to taking on the nfl in the fall and
what the argument of the book is that
president trump was hoping to do was to
get the league to the nfl to actually
take in the usfl teams and then
president trump would be the owner of an
nfl team which was really his goal the
entire time
and that kind of blew up in their face
but it's a wild story and it's told very
well colorado geezer tweets into you
as someone who comes from the only city
state city colorado denver
to turn down a winter olympics 1976.
state city in the united states to be
clear talk about what the olympics do to
cities that get the bid
and shout out to the people of boston
who pushed back a summer bid um i spoke
about this earlier with the super bowl
it applies very directly to the olympics
of debt displacement in the
militarization of public space and this
is something that's been a feature of
every olympic games
and it's a reason why city after city
today have actually been across the
world have been standing up voting in
referenda and trying to keep the
olympics out of their hometown because
particularly in the post-9 11 era
the weight of hosting these games is
actually destructive towards the city
not constructive
and in brazil i mean if you know what's
happening right now in brazil in terms
of its political and economic turmoil
it's you can't separate that from the
fact that it made the decision when
economic times were good of hosting the
world cup in 2014 and then the olympics
in 2016 back to back and i wrote a book
about that brazil's dance with the devil
and the devil in this case
of the of the book's title is these mega
events it is the olympics the devil uh
is the world cup the devil is this
operation uh that pushes for
what i would call a sporting shock
doctrine to use the words of naomi klein
where these sporting events come into
a country and they're able to play a
role in actually remaking the economic
priorities of a country but because they
come wrapped in sports they're able to
be pushed through so 2016 the
summer olympics were in rio correct yes
what's been the effect of all those
stadiums all that
housing everything going into the city
of rio
well i mean
has there been a positive side no no it
hasn't been a positive what it did was
it destroyed entire neighborhoods like a
place i went to often called villa
autodromo
it displaced people
it created a situation where a lot of
public services that people were
counting on were underfunded
and it also created a situation where
these mega events were branded with the
with the ruling workers party and it
opened space for this new far-right
leader named jair bolsonaro to come take
power and a lot of political analyses
aren't talking about this with the rise
of bolsonaro i mean bolsonaro is a in my
opinion a very scary figure in many
respects for how he speaks about women
how he speaks about gay people how he
speaks about what he wants to do to the
amazon rainforest how he speaks about
indigenous people there was just an
indigenous protest at the brazilian
embassy here in washington dc about
bolsonaro and then the political
analyses that i'm looking at there
really is nothing about the ways in
which the world cup in the olympics uh
helped pave this road for him to take
power because it bred so much anger and
dissatisfaction i mean in 2013 before
the world cup there were these mass
marches taking place on the stadiums as
they were being built so you had
brazilians by the thousands protesting
soccer i mean just think about that
would be like new yorkers protesting
pizza you would never see that and yet
you saw it in brazil
1968 yes mexico city
john carlos did not just come out of a
vacuum did he no he didn't tell me smith
no tommy smith and john carlos a lot of
people know that moment where john
carlos and tommy smith raised their
fists to the heavens in 1968 but they
don't realize that it was also a
movement called the olympic project for
human rights not just a moment but a
movement and this movement
was built for the liberation of black
athletes it was built
as a way to organize um
i guess what
not just a protest but a boycott of the
olympic games
and it was doing so around a series of
demands like disinviting south africa
and rhodesia
from the olympics like getting avery
brundage the head of the international
olympic committee whose nickname was
slavery avery uh getting him to step
down for what were perceived as his his
racism as head of the international
olympic committee
so it was built around a series of
demands and then when the boycott didn't
happen
tommy smith and john carlos felt like
they still needed to do something to
commemorate the struggle
and so in october of 1968 the summer
olympics were in october that year a lot
of people they're taken aback by that
but that was because the
storm season in the summer of mexico
they didn't want to have the olympics
then
but in october of 1968
they raised their fists but they didn't
just raise their fists with with gloves
on each hand they also weren't wearing
shoes
to protest poverty they were wearing
beads around their neck as a symbol of
the history of violence and lynching in
the united states
and they're all wearing buttons that
said olympic project for human rights
and it has to be mentioned that in the
silver medal stand was an australian
runner named peter norman who is also
wearing a button that said olympic
project for human rights
a tremendous show of solidarity and an
image that has stood the test of time
that and muhammad ali standing over
sunny liston i would argue are the two
uh most famous sports photos of the 20th
century well john carlos the john carlos
story is
co-authored by dave zirin yes and we
covered mr carlos back in 2011 on book
tv talking about his book here's a
little bit of what he had to say
and i go upstairs and i knock on the
door
a guy comes to the door open up the door
he looked for me to me
he invited me in i go on in
they offer me
cookies soda sandwich whatever i want
and i'm sitting down and i'm looking
some of these people look familiar
we've seen them on tv
but i'm still not putting the dots
together in terms of where i am
and then after about 20 minutes 25
minutes the door opens and here comes a
living legend walk out and first thing
i'm thinking to myself oh my god my
mother need to be a bug on my lapel or a
rock in my pocket cause dr king walked
out the room
who would ever thought that little
johnny carlos
would be in the room with dr king that
my household he was like god's first
lieutenant he sent the earth
and when he came in i realized right
away that not only was he a civil
activist or was he he was a minister but
if he wanted to be on saturday night
live standing up as a comic he'd made
grand theft money
because he knew how to crack some jokes
and relax the people
and he sure relaxed me because he showed
me and nearly shaking a little bit
i'm in there with the big boys
so he went on and he made this statement
he said listen
he said i want to come out and i want to
support this olympic boycott
i want to support the olympic boycott
i don't want to be in charge i want to
be second in command under harry edwards
and we went on and had the strategy
about what we're going to do and why
we're going to do and how we're going
gonna do and then he says out of nowhere
that he received the letter in the mail
and the letter said that they had a
bullet with his name on it and he
wouldn't have to wait long
but when he said that that's ringing in
my brain like a big gun
so at the end of the meeting he said do
you have any questions i couldn't wait
to throw my hand up
yeah dr king i got a couple of questions
first question did you ever play any
basketball did you box
could you run
he said i couldn't play who
i said why would you get involved in the
olympic movement and he said to me he
said listen he said imagine a boat in
the middle of a lake and everything is
still and serene the water is calm he's
said you take this rock out the boat and
you hold it over the side and drop it
what happens
i saw they get vibration he said
absolutely it creates waves go out to
the far ends of the lake
he said that olympic boycott is that
rock
he said if you guys chose to step back
from the olympic games the greatest
thing is that you're not killing anybody
you're not putting anybody down
as a man as a woman you're just making a
statement i'm choosing to step back and
he said to me also imagine what would
have happened if the black soldiers
decided to step back and not go to the
war do you think america would be as
great as it is today
i saw that's heavy put that in my little
basket
he said to me he said john you said you
had another question
yes dr king i have another question
you said that they say they have a
letter with a bullet with your name on
it
why would you go back to memphis and
when he said what he was about to say i
used to wear shades and they didn't
dilate like they do now and i pull my
shades down
i want to look in his eyes and i don't
want to look through no glass
why would i look in his eyes baby girl
why you think so
no not to connect if a man tell me
they're going to kill me and i don't
have to wait i just want to be a little
shaky
i'll look to see if he was afraid to die
he was as solid as the rock of gibraltar
and not only was he he did not have no
fear but when you look in someone's eyes
you know when love is in the eyes
he loves society so much until he was
ready to give his life and when you look
at a picture of gandhi you see the same
love when you look at rosa parks you see
the same love of paul robertson the same
love and my hero john brown when you
look in his eyes you see the same love
these individuals made the ultimate
commitment they didn't make a partial
commitment
john collins did not make a partial
commitment in 1968 if it was partial i
wouldn't be here in 2011.
my day is done
but my day is not done because the war
that we started years ago long time
before 68 it still goes on today
1968
i'll tell you guys about those applause
in a minute
i got how much a minute and a half
all right all right
all right
well they got a time schedule so we got
to keep up with it
so anyway
in 1968
when you sit back and you think about it
we were young and idealistic as david
said and we had a vision a paradigm in
terms of how can we make society better
we looked at individuals that stood up
and all those individuals died just like
that one individual stepped out to try
and move that pebble he couldn't do it
by himself dr king died gandhi died rosa
parks all of them died malcolm died
because they was out there by themselves
it was the leaders by itself
and then we said well let's get these
young individuals together let's try and
make them understand this thing called
the olympic movement
is 15 minutes in the sun for any young
individual to go to the olympics you got
15 minutes if i asked most of you guys
in there who won the mall at the last
olympics you couldn't tell me
if i asked you two olympics to go who's
the 100 meter winner you couldn't tell
me
so i said you got 15 minutes so
idealistically we decided to get this
theory going let's get on this train and
have some discussion y'all wanting to
discuss it well man i don't know about
me boycotting the olympics i promised my
church i was going to win i
trained too hard my mother's expecting
me to win i can't give up my opportunity
to go to the olympics i'm going to get
this job from the olympics
and we said well look man all we want to
do is try and have some dialogue so we
can have some exchange and tell you
which you can do greater than that 15
minutes
well okay i'm willing to do that so we
get on this hypothetical train and we
start rolling down the tracks
now all the people outside the train
they waving god bless america with
russia with cuba make sure you bring
home the gold make our medal count high
they was all excited
now we come to the conclusion that hey
we gonna do this thing we gonna attempt
to make this olympic boycott possible
everybody understand that we're gonna
make a better situation we gonna make
society better
now everybody was at the crossroads in
life just like you facing your
crossroads at one point or another in
your life
now we got the thing where we saying
okay we on the same page we're going to
attempt to do something collectively
like we come together as a unit
and now that we said we're going to do
this
let's stop the train let's put out the
banners on the train potential olympic
boycott or black athletes and anyone
that's sympathetic to the cause 1916
olympic boy because all the banners all
the way down the train
now we start to train up again now all
those people that was out there yippee
cayenne and waving they're gone
why because just where america was we
talk about boycotting the olympic games
i don't want to hear that
you ain't supposed to be concerned about
yourself you supposed to be concerned
about america well where's america when
i say be concerned about me
that's the question so now we sit back
we look at him we say okay
all the people that was out there waving
is gone but some replaced them
what replaced them was fire bombs
missiles that they shot at the train
that 43 years that tommy smith and john
collins and peter norman was out there
43 years we dealt with bombs and chaos
and murder and mayhem
and then you sit back and you say here
we are 43 years later and now look
life and change
from the villain all of a sudden we was
resurrected as god's children we're the
heroes now
and that was john carlos back in 2011
talking about the 1968 olympics so the
olympic games bring together nations
in a
contest of athleticism
and it's a solid
good thing to do yeah i'm not there
i'll tell you this if they could
structure the olympic games so they
would be in one set location every four
years then we could start to have a
discussion about them and how they
operate but the fact that they go from
city to city in an almost viral fashion
and leave behind them this wreckage of
debt displacement and hyper
militarization i mean that's the sort of
thing that i can never get my head
around or support like if the olympics
were coming to this town i would be
protesting and i would be protesting not
out of some altruistic belief of what
the olympics are but i'd be protesting
because my wife's a public school
teacher and i would be concerned about
what the olympics coming here would do
to school funding i would be concerned
about what would happen to her students
when you have the hyper militarization
that takes place and what they call
these states of exception where that
brings in all sorts of military hardware
into a city for the duration of the
olympics and all sort of surveillance
technology you know we spoke earlier
about the super bowl and the ways in
which uh the commercials are such an
attraction and the way madison avenue
loves the super bowl because it's their
time to shine basically
the olympics are where the surveillance
industry
that's what they see is their time to
shine they hold these incredible expos
where the people who run
the olympics they come out and they see
all the latest doodads in terms of
recording people and and finding out
where they're going and how and how to
basically be operational in a way that
removes any pretense of civil liberties
that we might want to have
and oftentimes
that that maintains itself i'll never
forget i was in london for the olympics
they had there in 2012 i wasn't there to
go to the events i was there to do
reporting
and there was um
i heard the story of a police official
who was asked about the surveillance
equipment coming in
and he was asked the question
well what's going to happen to all the
surveillance equipment afterwards after
the olympics and he said in a british
accent he said well it's not like we can
just put him back in the box then can we
and i thought the box is a heck of a
metaphor in this situation like once
this idea of a surveillance state comes
out of the box then it's very difficult
to put back in and that the olympics are
used as kind of the lubricant to make
that a reality that's a problem
but
didn't we sponsor we had here in
washington several years ago one of the
quarterfinals for the world cup didn't
we
for soccer that went pretty well didn't
it i mean i think that's going back to
uh am i that old 94 right i think is it
that long ago okay
okay i i but it's worthwhile to mention
i'm trying to segue into soccer here and
i i guess my example was pretty bad no
no no i think that 911 though has been
such a game changer in terms of the
surveillance and the militarization that
it makes it very difficult it's also
like the world cup i mean it's a
question like they're about to have the
world cup in qatar for example and
there's been um all this media coverage
about the use of slave labor to create
the stadiums the the deaths that have
taken place to make the world cup um
um just
hospitable and habitable for a country
like carter and qatar and
the the the
it's so much more difficult to stage in
a place like qatar than it would be like
in for example the united states where
you or you could do it in stadiums that
already exist in different cities and so
when you have that level of intensive
investment
uh you you develop these kinds of issues
and problems because the demands that
are made by fifa the world governing
body for soccer are as such that it will
create
and i'll use these phrases again the
debt displacement and militarization of
public space from brazil's dance with
the devil fifa president sepp blatter is
infamous for always insisting with the
regularity of a metronome no matter the
host country that the old stadiums are
simply not good enough
and that the country must build fifa
quality stadiums
and you refer to him in this book as the
slithering head of fifa yeah no longer
the slithering head of fifa now it's a
johnny boy infantino gianni infantility
johnny boy yeah as he's known uh
i love their names you got set bladder
you've got johnny boy
people can infer what i'm saying
and i i think that
the problem with this demand for fifa
quality stadiums is that it means that
the existing infrastructure is just not
going to be good enough
and because the existing infrastructure
isn't going to be good enough they're
the demands for these construction
projects and these construction projects
are invariably rushed invariably workers
die on these projects because of the
rush to get them built
and invariably they're
they're they're so hyper investment
focused and yet after the world cup is
over what's the use for these stadiums i
mean one of there was talk in brazil
about using one of the stadiums as an
open-air prison
afterwards uh in another stadium they
were talking about renting it out for
weddings
i mean there's just not a lot of use for
them particularly if they're built in a
space that isn't necessarily
a soccer mad environment i mean brazil
is a country that's bigger than the
continental united states it's not
soccer mad everywhere and yet they're
building stadiums in areas that aren't
necessarily going to use them when the
world cup was done and that's why there
were so many protests that were focused
on the stadiums because they became
these living symbols of a set of
economic priorities that
absolutely made people beyond upset
202 is the area code 748-8200 for those
of you in the east and central time
zones if you want to have a chat with
author and sports writer dave zirin
202-748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific you're not the only
writer in your family are you
no um my dad has written a couple of
books uh very proud of them they're
terrific books one is called the mother
court it's about the southern district
of new york a court that's gotten a lot
of publicity recently for reasons that
you may be familiar with hey there's my
dad up on the screen and he wrote a book
about the supreme court called supremely
partisan uh very proud of him
love my dad he's not a writer by trade a
lawyer by trade and i think he wanted me
to join the legal profession but i
didn't
and now he's joining the writing
profession
so uh makes me feel i don't know kind of
good in a circular sort of way
a family tree going full circle
but uh you know love my dad lots and
he's actually um he's a hero to me
because he just went to
the sundance because he's interviewed in
a movie
about donald trump's relationship with
roy cohn
uh the the infamous lawyer and fixer in
new york called where's my roy cohn and
so he got interviewed for that and they
they sent him out there was your dad
acquainted with mr cohn
uh i think he had met him a couple of
times but they were not uh acquainted no
uh
next call for dave zirin comes from ben
in new york city where dave's iron was
raised go ahead
dave how you doing it's uh ben shapiro
hey ben shapiro
to be clear not not the right wing
pundit ben shapiro but a brilliant
baseball mind named ben shapiro there is
more than one absolutely important
important clarification and thank you
for that um i was just wondering what
your thoughts were about the upcoming uh
baseball season and also how you see uh
mookie beth's place
in history of boston sports given its uh
racial issues now mr shapiro tell us
about yourself what do you do
i actually don't write that much anymore
but i i was for a period of time
uh did some baseball writing uh for a
bleacher report and mathlive.com and uh
have a twitter handle red sox monster
um so uh and dave and i have met a few
times ben's really good uh he knows a
lot about baseball more than i do he
should be answering this question
uh more than i should i mean i'll give
my answer ben and if you have a
different one go right ahead
um i think mookie betts is going to be
remembered possibly as a transformative
figure i mean first of all given his
success on the diamond and now his
refusal to go to the trump white house
i mean it puts him very much in in the
crosshairs in the history of boston
sports of people who might not like
their black athletes to be political and
yet i think he's going to transcend that
and be the kind of player who people
rally around and i think that's what's
going to make him i think important and
remembered beyond for what he just does
on the field
mr shapiro i mean i i
was going to say i think he's got a
chance to really
leave his mark in a number of ways on
the city and on major league baseball as
well of course
a big factor is going to be whether or
not he stays in boston you never know in
this crazy baseball world but i i would
anticipate them
going all out to resign him he is
really uh i mean i would say after brady
right now
he's probably the most popular athlete
in boston which is
saying a lot uh given given boston's
sports history
and i'll throw one more question at ben
about this upcoming baseball season what
do you make of all these free agents not
being signed what is that about and is
that a failure of the union
well i mean i know a lot about baseball
dave but you probably know a little bit
more about uh the history of the union
than i do and i would
i would go so far as to suggest and i
think i'm i know i'm not the only person
suggesting this but i think there will
probably end up being a collusion
investigation if this continues because
machado and harper
are
it's rare to get two free agents of that
caliber
in the same season and there really
isn't even that much heat around them in
fact there's more owners out there
saying they don't want them then they do
want them and i know that they've had
some issues as far as you know you get
the reporting on the attitude and this
that or the other but there's no
questioning the talent and the youth
so why these guys remained unsigned is
uh is going to be a big question
and i think i think the owner's gonna
have to answer it at some point it's
them and hundreds of other players right
now who are unsigned in a major league
baseball um and it it does represent
ourselves
by collusion he means that the owners
actually deciding among themselves
uh just like they in the nfl they
allegedly have decided to not sign colin
kaepernick or at least that's what his
lawsuit uh pretends but that they've
decided that they're not going to sign
these two incredible free agents he
mentioned them by last name one is manny
machado famously with the baltimore
orioles finished last season with the
dodgers and bryce harper of course with
the washington nationals i mean both of
these players were rumored to get 300
400 million dollar contracts so the
collusion is saying
as a league we don't want to go there
right that's actually they're not
allowed to do that that's a violation of
union law
and when they've been caught doing that
in the past it's cost them tens of
millions of dollars this could cost them
hundreds of millions of dollars but it's
very difficult to prove collusion there
needs to be a smoking gun there needs to
be a whistleblower there needs to be a
paper trail it's not enough just to say
like in kaepernick's case for example oh
there's so many terrible quarterbacks
being signed how could he not be signed
this is just ridiculous or in this case
to say oh this is bryce harper this is
manny machado these are generational
talents how are they not being signed
that's not enough to prove collusion
you do need something that is
transparently concrete
dave zirin you mentioned the la dodgers
dodger stadium's one of the icons of the
league
and no controversy about
chavez ravine so much controversy about
chavez ravine i mean chavez ravine was
once known as the poor man shangri-la it
was a community of latino of mexican
immigrants
and it was apparently this incredibly
beautiful space that they had created
among themselves
as a place to settle in los angeles
and you know
word of chavez ravine and this poor man
shangri-la would reach its way
south of the border to mexico and people
would make the pilgrimage to live in
this area
and
that area was was torn apart
interestingly it was first torn apart
for public housing
and people
tried to protest and they sat in at
chavez ravine
and then
uh there there was this like incredible
twist like a novel by james elroy for
example some pulpy novel about about
south los angeles where the people who
are promoting the public housing were
accused of being communists and they
were brought in front of the house on
american activities committee
and you had then you had all of this
land and then the land was grabbed with
the help of an actor by the name of
ronald reagan who uh promoted it heavily
and they were able to create this
stadium for the now los angeles dodgers
who at the time were playing in the
coliseum and that's been open since 62 i
believe yeah and it's the first stadium
land grab you could say was chavez
ravine and there's a terrific musical
album by i believe ry cooter called the
battle of chavez ravine that goes
through the entire history and story
zoot suit riots happened there as well
yes raymond kalamazoo michigan hi
raymond
yes
i just wanted to say that mrs barry is
such a hero of mine and this is this
thought this was so long overdue
mr sam you are such a hero of mine as
well
one giant interviewing another giant and
this this
uh platform from mr zarin is long
overdue his voice said should be heard
more often and there should be more
uh
journalists of integrities first
especially have spoken integrity as mr
zirin and and bullies for years so
what a great show this is and i want to
say thank you
both so much and god bless this man god
bless you both so much raymond thank you
for calling in i should mention that i'm
huge in kalamazoo no not really that was
a joke uh but but just to say i really
do appreciate that i mean one of the
things that i've when i started doing
this work back in 2005 i used to make a
joke where i would say oh you could take
all the political sports writers and we
could have our annual meeting inside a
phone booth uh it just wasn't this thing
that people did it was a very shallow
pond and it's been very gratifying in
recent years to see like this generation
of people writing politically about
sports and athletes speaking out
politically and understanding like the
power of this platform which i think got
forgotten for a good solid 20 years
there as it became really all about uh
corporate sponsorship and making money
and and the disavow of politics
i'm not sure what league it's in but
kalamazoo has a professional hockey team
wow they play against the fort wayne
comets and in that midwest it used to be
the international hockey league and
there's a whole
i don't know what do you call it
semi-pro or do you call it uh yeah i
think you'd call it semi-pro you might
call it minor league hockey minor league
and and uh fort wayne a place where you
have some roots of course absolutely and
some some a lot of a lot of
minor league teams in that area
do they have the same
issues that we're talking about here
with the
professional teams
that's a great question i mean i would
imagine so just because of the pipeline
not producing the players but
but i would need to investigate that
further as has been said to me often
when i've traveled and done talks to
canada my hockey knowledge is not nearly
what it should be with regards to other
things are some of the issues that we're
talking about unique to the us or do
they are they international issues oh
they're international i mean they
certainly play themselves out in
different character in other countries
like racism can play itself out very
differently in europe than here sexism
plays itself itself out very differently
in south america than it does in the
united states there are certainly common
denominators
in terms of progress in terms of
movements in terms of leading figures i
mean those things are are very
indigenous to the country themselves but
as far as like the broader basic
struggles like how do you eliminate
racism in european soccer how do the
women's soccer teams in south america
get greater recognition and greater
funding
these are battles that have an
international component and it's
fascinating to study and compare and
contrast how it plays out in different
ways one thing i've learned from
traveling though is that what happens in
the united states has a real impact
around the world like things like title
ix legislation or the movement of women
in sports when kaepernick took a knee
for example
players of color were taking these in
the soccer leagues around the world i
mean so so what happens in the united
states gets watched very closely by
these different leagues around the world
next call for dave zirin comes from john
in alpena michigan john you're on book
tv
hey dave hey john peter
um
just a first time caller on book tv
peter you've done a wonderful job over
the years i love your stuff
and
the question for dave is you know today
being super bowl sunday
and the nfl you know we all know it
makes a lot of money oh yeah i was
wondering about the ncaa and the
paper play
what your thoughts are on that oh it's a
great question thank you for calling in
john are you an nc do you have an ncaa
team that you follow
oh yes yes uh
i'm a notre dame irish guy ah there you
go wow in michigan too which is very
brave so yeah nicely done sir um
i
it's so interesting because i i am
against the idea of these players not
being paid for what they produce i think
ncaa athletes who produce revenue should
be paid for the revenue they produce i
think it's there's something
absolutely unseemly about coaches who
get paid millions of dollars television
deals that rake in billions of dollars
and yet the position of the player is
largely powerless this is a problem and
it needs to be rectified and i think
that the ncaa is really the source of
the problem in that it's the great
protector of this system but i think the
nfl is part of the problem as well and
that they love having this kind of free
minor league that allows them
to develop talent without them having to
actually invest any money in it the
people investing the money in it are
really the students
and the public
and the rise of things like activity
fees on college campuses and the rise of
tuition on college campuses i mean a lot
of that goes into supporting these kinds
of big money high revenue sports
programs
the caller steve
mentioned
notre dame
and i think you look at a place like
like notre dame it says so much about
the way sports has developed
in this country i mean college football
in particular because notre dame i mean
it used to be this small college in what
was a textile community in south bend
indiana
that had a football team that got a lot
of national recognition of course
but now notre dame is the industry in
south bend there's no more textile
industry in south bend and it's whether
or not notre dame has a good season or
not has such an economic ripple effect
throughout south bend
and we we don't usually take a step back
and ask ourselves is this a healthy
state of circumstances where an entire
town an entire small city is dependent
on the success of what our so-called
amateurs playing this sport for coaches
who make millions of dollars
in michael bennett and dave zirin's book
things that make white people
uncomfortable one chapter is entitled
the ncaa will give you
ptsd yeah this is comes from michael i
mean the book is michael through and
through and this was his formulation
about the post-traumatic stress syndrome
of of
of playing
um in the ncaa because there are a
couple things that happen when you play
in the ncaa and you play big time
college football
uh the first is that you become addicted
to the acclaim and the accolades and so
you become addicted to what robert
lipscite who we mentioned earlier the
great sports writer for the new york
times he would call it the warm so you
become addicted to the warm of all these
people idolizing you and when that warm
goes away
because only a huge tiny tiny minority
of players will actually make the pros
so when the warm goes away they all of a
sudden feel like there's nothing there
for them
and that creates a form of ptsd the
other part
that michael was referring to is
an addiction to violence and an
addiction to
uh just the the the feel and the emotion
of basically getting into what amounts
to a car accident a week whether you're
talking about practice and playing as
well
and he mentions a player in the book who
was caught on camera like running
through a playglass window
just to feel something again
and a lot of players also talk about
michael speaks about this in the book
about players who way after the fact
said you know i think i'm depressed and
there's nowhere to really talk about
mental health no space to talk about it
no space to talk about the adjustment of
of being on this college campus and
getting all this warm and then finding
out that you really are left with
nothing when it's all said and done
because you weren't allowed to take the
classes you wanted to take you weren't
able to devote the time to your studies
you weren't able to take advantage of
that scholarship and that's what people
always say like oh you can't pay the
players they're getting this great
education without asking ourselves well
what's the substance of that education
what are they actually able to study
what are they able to learn and what is
that degree worth when they're done
are we in the
evolution not revolution period do you
think of athletes being paid absolutely
absolutely and it's moving faster than
maybe i wish you could call it with a
word for it like the rev evolution
because you are seeing more and more
athletes stand up and assert their power
i just interviewed recently kane coulter
who is the quarterback for northwestern
when they attempted to form a union at
northwestern and that's an incredible
story in and of itself
and i think you're seeing more and more
players like openly and social media has
helped with this but openly speak about
the recognition that they're being
exploited by playing college sports
and all it would take really would be a
couple of teams refusing to play
and wanting things like health care
before they got back on the field or
wanting to be able to have some sort of
mediation process if they felt like they
were being worked too hard you know 17
players have died in off-season drills
since the year 2000
in the ncaa if that number was in the
nfl there would be congressional
hearings about the state of the sport
and yet these things happen and they're
barely remarked upon uh this news came
out uh with the death of a player right
near us at the university of maryland uh
this past year uh by the name of jordan
mcnair so
so i think there's so much that needs to
change with the ncaa
whether or not they're going to change
without being forced to change is
another question but one thing we saw a
couple of years ago was the players at
the university of missouri
they made the decision that they were
not going to play as a protest against
racism
and the school president
who said he was going to hang on and
last because there were all these
protests on campus he basically lasted
less than a week at that point because
the school was going to have to
sacrifice a million dollars a week
if the players were not taking the field
who's the head of the ncaa and what does
he or she get paid mark emmert i mean
his uh
his pay is something that's subject to a
lot of scrutiny and questions it's
believed to be
over 2 million a year keep in mind that
the ncaa is a non-profit
it's a non-profit that makes a lot of
profit
it was it stripped away its own
non-profit status because it was a
couple of years ago because it was
getting so much guff
for that fact
uh yeah the ncaa
and the nfl
as recently as a few years ago were both
declared non-profits which is really
stunning if you think about it because i
mean i don't know a lot of non-profits
where there are 14 vice presidents each
of whom make about 400 000 a year and
and upwards
but that's uh how the ncaa operates i i
view it as as taylor branch the great
civil rights writer views it as a cartel
which is this closed kind of operation
that exists as a mechanism
for the exploitation of these athletes
but it exists because we want their
product right yes but we would still
want their product if players were paid
i mean that's the part that that to me
is the most transparently wrong about
their arguments like i think if players
actually received some sort of salary
for the revenue they brought in and the
money's there i mean the money's there
when you see coaches have nine million
dollar contracts annual contracts 10
million contracts i mean the sport has
changed so dramatically
i did an interview on a sports radio
show speaking about this very subject
and the person i was talking about the
importance of players being paid and the
purse the host said to me you know if
i'd had you on my show 10 years ago i
would have called you a nut and made fun
of you and gotten callers to call in and
make fun of you and done all this thing
but but now when i look at the money
that's being generated i i can't make
fun of you anymore it's just too obvious
and i was sort of like well thank you i
think but either way i hear what you're
saying because the coach of clemson
clemson just won the ncaa football
championship coach of clemson dabo
swinney uh he makes i think seven and a
half million dollars a year somewhere in
that range with all the bonuses that he
got
clemson won the national championship in
1981. their coach danny ford made fifty
thousand dollars that year
so how does a fifty thousand dollar a
year job become an eight million dollar
a year job how does that happen
and you have to look at the growth of
cable television and you have to look at
the growth of corporate advertising and
then you have to ask yourself why do the
people whose blood sweat and tears
actually create this sport not see some
of that
where can people hear your radio show
and when
oh well thank you for asking i do a
podcast called the edge of sports
podcast people can get that off of apple
on itunes and i do a show called the
collision
on wpfw that's pacifica radio here in
washington dc it's available online at
the pfw website it's also podcast that
shows the collision i do alongside a
10-year nba veteran by the name of atan
thomas who's a a terrific friend of mine
and a terrific human being and he just
wrote a book called we matter athletes
and activism where he interviews a lot
of athletes and family members of people
who've been touched by police violence
and he he weaves it all together in a
beautiful way i mean he's truly suey
generous as we say
and uh did i say that right okay good
and so atan and i we do this show
together and we have a lot of fun and
that's if you look up edge of sports
you'll be able to find dave's iron show
atan thomas has also appeared on book tv
go to booktv.org type in his name up at
the search bar type in dave zirin's name
up at the search bar type in any of our
authors names up in the search bar you
can watch them all online at your
leisure lose in vancouver washington
thanks for holding your own book tv with
author dave zyra
great talking to you dave hey great
talking to you too um
i want to get back to the public
financing of
of stadiums and one thing that has never
talked about i've never heard one word
of it you know in a public
environment is about the idea of eminent
domain
now we don't want bureaucrats you know
seizing and running the teams but
why couldn't we
uh
have
give uh if a you know a
state in locality or
builds a stadium for a team white one
station they have the right of eminent
domain to keep the team from moving just
to hold the team i'm all for it
my
my own personal uh belief i think the
model for
sports franchise ownership should be the
green bay packers
something we talked about a little bit
earlier in great agreement with this uh
and i'm sure our our caller from
vancouver washington is still smarting
over the moving of the seattle sonics
uh which was partly due to howard
presidential aspirant howard schultz uh
selling the team to the bennett family
who then moved the team to as everyone
knew they would to oklahoma city to
create the oklahoma city thunder
the use of
eminent domain is something that is
somehow written into the sports bylaws
of certainly of major league baseball to
say that this would not be allowed they
wrote into the bylaws after joan crock
passed away and wanted to leave the san
diego padres to the city of san diego
and they said no no this can never
happen cities cannot own teams cities
cannot run teams when to me it makes so
much sense for to run it this way i mean
imagine every time you saw a jersey from
your local team or a flag
waving from the back of a car that you
knew that that money was actually going
back into the city instead of into the
pockets of people like the
aforementioned dan snyder that would be
a very nice thing and it would also mean
that say that teams could not move so a
team like the seattle sonics would be a
team that would still exist in seattle
and it is an absolute travesty that
there is not professional basketball in
the city of seattle so dave zirin who's
the governing board of some of these big
leagues the nba
nfl mlb is it the owners yeah period you
know they think it's moses they act like
moses came down from mount sinai with
the bylaws and these bylaws can never be
changed because thou shalt ordain that
there will be bylaws and cities cannot
run teams but it really is the owners uh
the owners they have their ownership
meetings uh they're a board of governors
uh with these leagues as well who are a
select group of owners but all the
owners pretty much have an equal say in
how the leagues are running they are
looking out for each other history oh
yeah and then and so you don't want to
create precedent where i've heard this
uh from from one owner where he funded
his own stadium and he told me about how
much
backlash he got from other owners i mean
even though it was his money and his
business and his team and his city and
all the rest of it uh they were upset
with him because of the precedent that
that which that that would um create
and it could create pressure on them as
well
so
there there is this kind of mutual both
um solidarity and distrust
art model the late owner of first the
cleveland browns and then the baltimore
ravens
he called football owners he called them
28 capitalists who act like socialists
and uh so it was when he was trying to
to get uh he was he was a bit of a
jokester and what he was trying to get
across was that these are
28 at the time it was 28 that these are
28 like incredibly
wealthy people who made their money uh
through through private ownership who
then look out for each other who pool
the money who create a situation where
uh where they watch each other's
interests in the broad scheme of the
league and aren't trying to actually
destroy each other within the league
because they know that uh you know that
if say one team is perpetually terrible
it actually hurts the entire product
let's hear from christy christie is in
portland oregon hi christy you're on
with author dave zirin
hi dave and peter thank you to both of
you for your invaluable contribution to
the public dialogue
um dave your books have been the feats
of strengths
awards for my annual festivus for years
um it's it's
very popular
um
you mean i'm part of a festivus holiday
tradition
absolutely since 2010. this warms my
heart like you do not even know because
that really is the holiday for the rest
of us
absolutely
so just kind of con continuing with the
theme as you know we've had to
resist against the paulsons trying to
build a
baseball stadium and they may be
successful at some point it comes it
continues to come up
we had success with our soccer teams and
portland pilots because there was an
existing baseball stadium so there
really wasn't um you know
we didn't have to do a major investment
in reorganizing our
economy and that sort of thing and it's
actually been very successful and that's
a great franchise um
but at this point
other than
making city councils around the country
required reading game over and behead
sports to educate themselves
on you know the pulses of the world
trying to influence
and make these projects happen
what can we do because it is these are
very complicated
concepts and i think that you know
governors
and senators you know they have the
apparatus around them to be informed
they can fight back with studies and
things like that but a local city
council person who actually ends up
making
unfortunately of the bad decisions on
deregulations and other kinds of local
of things that uh
basically they're they don't have the
apparatus to to understand really that
they're playing christie we'll get an
answer here are you a sports fan at all
christy
absolutely what sports do you like
well i'm a huge oregon duck
football fan but just ducks all the way
and i just prefer college sports it is
changed a lot through the years with the
influence of money but i still feel like
it's a game where
um you know people can
politics are a part of it but you don't
feel as much as
professional sports and i have you read
the book university of nike
i have not okay all right well christy
thank you for calling in we'll spend a
little time with your with what you had
to say i want to start though before we
get an answer for christy i just want to
add a little something she what she was
talking about this is from your book
from bad sports
quote at the same moment his father was
demanding 700 billion dollars of our
money to bail out banks
merit paulson was agitating for his own
little piece of the action he embarked
on a public campaign for 85 million
dollars in public funds from the city of
portland oregon to build a new sports
complex for the beavers and an upgrade
on the timbers stadium
who was merritt paulson and who was his
father merritt paulson the son of hank
paulson hank paulson who was uh the
secretary of the treasury um on the end
of the bush administration who was in
charge during the big wall street
bailout and so the i mean as a sports
writer i mean you you live for these
kinds of of
kismet moments where you have hank
paulson demanding all of this money and
then you have his son merritt paulson
and what a terrific dickensian name
merritt paulson um
also
demanding a great deal of public funds
as well
and you know the city of portland was
was very heroic and opposing this and i
think if
i think to speak to something directly
that christie raised i think we don't
realize how powerful city council people
are in this process like if you can
because you ask what could be done if we
can get our city councils to pass
legislation that says like we reject the
use of public funds or we demand for
every dollar of public funds that go
into a stadium project one dollar goes
into a library fund or a school fund or
the like you'd be surprised at how
powerful and how binding that kind of
legislation can be even in the face of
lobbyists and of governorships and
mayorals mayoral power grabs and all the
rest of it so i would argue for people
to stick fighting on the grassroots
level and to not give up on the idea
that your city council can be a place
where pressure can be applied to make
sure that these stadium land grabs don't
take place
did the paulsons get their money during
2008-2009
i don't think they got it in full
because i think people
had the right kind of uh opposition in
portland and then we heard christy say
that she was a ducks fan yes
this is from your book game over oh boy
i visited the university of oregon a
proud institution whose budget is being
slashed to the bone
buildings are crumbling and the faculty
and staff have been forced to take
unpaid furloughs to make up for budget
shortfalls yet the school is not in a
state of complete disrepair
thanks to nike's emperor in charge phil
knight the school's athletic department
particularly its football program is
flush with cash forget vegas atlantic
city or monte carlo you haven't truly
seen excess until you've toured the new
41.7 million dollar athletic center
welcome to the ncaa in the 21st century
about as corrupt and mangled an
institution as exists on the sports
landscape
i i i got to stop pulling my punches
there it is
first and foremost it's always an
interesting experience when your own
words are read back to you and then i'm
like oh did i write that
i i did write that i mean i i've done
some events at the university of oregon
and the influence of nike ism is really
remarkable i mean you mentioned the book
uh it's called the university of nike
right and which i've read which is quite
good
and it details the way the the corporate
influence of nike on this particular
university and and that exists at other
universities as well
and i i just think that like we have we
have this uh devil's marriage uh between
um between high octane high highly
financed sports and institutions of
higher learning and it tends to to
mangle to mangle it i mean it does and
when you have a situation at the
university of oregon that deals with
these kinds of budget shortfalls while
the sports program is flush it sends a
message to the entire community that you
know this is a place where we stage
football games that happens to have
classes on the weekdays
phil knight
speaking in 2012 at the memorial service
for joe paterno
it turns out he gave full disclosure to
his superiors information that run up
the chain to the head of the campus
police and the president of the school
the matter was in the hands of a
world-class university and by a
president with an outstanding national
reputation
whatever the details that investigation
are this much is clear to me
there is a villain in this tragedy that
lies in that investigation
not in joe paterno's response to it
yikes
um
wow i mean
there's there's so much there i mean
there there's the attempt to to
whitewash history there's uh an effort
to
uh
to change the legacy of joe paterno at a
time where people were reckoning with
what he knew or what he didn't know
um about
uh child abuse that had taken place um
at the hands of jerry sandusky his
longtime assistant
and there's the ways in which the
relationship between nike and penn state
has been very lucrative for both parties
and i mean there was a whole prof i
believe performance center at uh the
nike university campus in beaverton
oregon that was named after joe paterno
there was also a performance center
named after lance armstrong on that same
campus i mean so you get these figures
and we build them up and then you know
we find out tough truths about them i
think the important thing for us whether
we call whether we're journalists or
whether we're public figures like phil
knight
corporate leaders is you have to reckon
with that history and the actuality of
that history
not attempt to whitewash it and i think
what we just saw was
a degree of demagoguery at a public
service where a standing ovation he knew
would be a fiat complete for what he
said and what he said was was dishonest
i mean there's some of what he said
that's actually
true and defensible in terms of how the
investigation took place uh certainly
the role of the ncaa after that
investigation and certainly and i wrote
about this the way that um
the the influence
that
that took place in terms of the governor
of the state and what they knew in their
investigation of sandusky there's a lot
of ugliness when it comes to what
happened at penn state but the idea that
joe paterno escapes all culpability in
this process i think is is ridiculous
and only someone with absolute blinders
would would take that as the result that
was quite a standing ovation it was that
remark said that was that was uh that's
called getting a hometown pop i mean he
knew what he was doing
ron's in rapid city south dakota hi ron
hi dave
just a couple of a a couple of short
issues for you and then i'll hang up and
take your
answer off the air the first one
a couple of callers ago stole my thunder
but i'm still interested in in in
i i bought and read your book
bad sports yes sir
and
what i want to know is why in the hell
don't these cities use their power of
condemnation
to take these teams over and hold them
in the cities
you know and i and i
and i'll say you know i uh for years i
was a municipal corporations lawyer and
i know
that you know you can use that that
power of imminent domain for virtually
anything
and
i don't know why
uh rather than you know ladling out
billions of dollars
for stadiums and so forth
that the these cities don't take
use that power of imminent domain
to take these corporations over and
that's not something that you addressed
in you know in the book
and
i think it deserves a lot more attention
than you're giving it okay
we're gonna have to leave it there
it's a terrific question and i i do
think i address it in the book in
concrete examples
um about eminent domain but in in terms
of getting in the weeds of it i mean how
often has eminent domain been used
historically in a way that actually
benefits people as opposed to i mean i
think eminent domains you've been used
much more to actually build stadiums as
opposed to using them to affect the
ownership of stadiums it's not never
used to affect the ownership of stadiums
but eminent domain has been used it was
used
here in the dc area as part of building
a nationals park where the nationals
play as a way to take out some of the
neighborhood to build the stadium itself
and so some of it is just how eminent
domain is used in our society but he's
absolutely correct that i mean the power
is there if we're willing to fight for
it to be exercised but it's not going to
be exercised by accident because i think
politicians they have what we can call
an edifice complex
there's nothing they like more than
funding these stadiums because everybody
loves sports and you could pose next to
the stadium and this can become the
legacy of what you did and people
associate it with all kinds of joy and
and good feelings and and maybe they can
say well the team would have moved if we
hadn't built it yet at the end of the
day it's just not go a good investment
and it becomes instead i mean monuments
to corporate greed and corporate welfare
donald emails in the kneeling protests
insult a nation that offers
opportunities to all races and anyone
who has more discipline than ego you
cannot achieve what football players
have professionally without that ethic
we reject the protests because they are
ungrateful and self-deceiving if black
lives mattered to these players the
players would teach teach what it takes
to succeed my goodness i mean first i
mean where do you even begin with that
the first is the idea that
players
don't work extensively in their
communities to try to teach young people
what it means to succeed i mean shows
that this particular person who wrote in
has no idea about how players spend
their time when they're not on the field
the second thing is calling them
ungrateful i mean that's a very sort of
ugly word because what they're trying to
do is use their platform to say to speak
a reality to an audience that is not
hearing that reality and that's i think
what what made
the reaction
so visceral by white america against
these protests is that what the athletes
were doing is invading their space to
speak about police brutality and try to
say to them hey this matters and if and
if we matter to you in terms of
as athletes and in terms of people to
cheer for then this should matter to you
as well because this is a concern in our
community so there's nothing ungrateful
about them doing it in fact what they
did i mean showed tremendous courage and
tremendous risk if it didn't you
wouldn't get responses like that i mean
i think that response shows exactly what
the players were were reckoning with
every time they made the decision to
take that knee it was a powerful
statement it was a risky statement colin
kaepernick has lost his job because of
that statement and i think the risk in
and of itself uh means and translates
into into our respect whether you agree
or disagree they sacrificed something
because they saw a greater issue that
needed to be brought to the fore email
linda
the cost of attending professional
sporting events is not affordable for
average working folks is there any
concern by franchises to address this no
because and i'll tell you why because um
ticket sales are not necessarily where
the money is the money is in public
subsidies the money is in what are
called psls or personalized seat
licenses those are the high-end seats
that people
actually purchase a seat the money is in
the corporate sponsorships
the money is not in the working class
fan who's oh and the money of course is
also in sweetheart cable deals the money
is not repeat
not in the average fan being able to
enjoy their game now what i wrote about
in bad sports was that i think this is
owners being incredibly short-sighted i
mean not seeing beyond the nose on their
face as you will because at the end of
the day your team is only going to have
that energy
that demands the public support to get
the public subsidies to get the
sweetheart cable deal and all the rest
of it if working-class fans are into it
and i mean so that's where the energy
really comes from it comes from an
entire city being behind a team and if
owners don't make it so
so regular working class folks can
actually attend games they're going to
lose that energy and if they lose that
energy they're going to lose public
support for their teams
a few minutes left with our guest
muhammad in dearborn michigan you're on
book tv
good afternoon thank you for having me
second time caller i
i spoke back in 2012
my question is
i wanted to know is
i think we just mentioned that should uh
are our professional athletes being uh
are they still being considered role
models
for other teams or only just the
activism small activism that they're
playing in
muhammad did you grow up with athletes
as role models
uh well my grandmother was uh muhammad
ali and kareem abdul-jabbar and uh
let me see yeah muhammad came up to
jabar uh
you know i didn't grow up with them but
watch them on tv all the time
yeah thank you sir no
no athletes are and will continue to be
role models should they be
should they be
i think in a absolutely
sane world of our own making than it
would be the people who sacrifice of
themselves on a day in day out basis
nurses teachers firefighters these would
be the role models of our society i just
think it's because of our addiction in
this country to fame and money and and
also our addiction to sports itself
something that many of us take part in
in our youth that just creates the
necessary soil
for the the growth of athletes as role
models so i that's what i was saying
earlier in the show is that these
athletes are role models whether we
choose to see them as role models or not
they just objectively are i mean if a
player from the washington wizards
walked into my son's elementary school
time would stop it would be so intense
if that took place
and so then we really do need to ask
ourselves though what are they modeling
so i think like the idea of like saying
the athletes like okay like having a
social conscience is also about having a
social responsibility towards the young
people who look up to you i think that's
very fair in this political climate
next call miles is in brooklyn miles
good afternoon you're on with dave zirin
hi dave um i think admirer her very
important body of work
um and you covered a lot of good ground
here today it's been really a good show
um but what i want to ask about is the
nfl players association
probably the weakest of the
um
unions for the big four american sports
and i'm wondering if you see a pathway
or a labor strategy for them to get
guaranteed contracts
um
because you know
in a sport where the careers are so
short and participants absorb such
brutality
it seems criminal that they're the only
ones that don't have
guaranteed contracts
so it seems like it would be very
important for them too miles you say
they don't have guaranteed contracts can
you give a little background there
well owners can
can uh fire a player and stop paying
them anytime they want to
um unlike in baseball or basketball or
even hockey where the the union isn't
very strong either
and
football players have the shortest
careers they
absorb the most punishment on behalf of
their job
and yet they have the weakest union the
least solidarity
and
the worst
collective bargaining agreement and it's
it seems upsetting and uh
i would like to see that
changed dramatically and i don't know if
there's a way among these um
there's one way miles
the players to uh to move in a more
positive direction all right thank you
sir it's a great question miles there's
only one way and that's the power of the
strike of players withholding their
labor
when the next collective bargaining
agreement comes up if they do that but
keep in mind that this is a golden goose
i mentioned it before that owning a nfl
team is like being a bartender on spring
break i mean the money is there and it
is by far the most lucrative of the big
four sports and so if players actually
withheld their labor
then the power
would be
i mean the power unleashed would be
unbelievable now the question becomes
though can players strike can they feel
like they afford to strike can they feel
like they can afford to sit out a year
and sacrifice a year of earnings when as
you mentioned the average career is only
three and a half years so there's an old
expression in the labor movement the
best way to win a strike is to prepare
for one i mean players would have to be
saving money over the course of several
years
and be very frugal with their money for
the purposes
of a strike because the nfl owners are
not going to give that up they they from
their perspective the injury rate is so
high and the injury rate by the way in
the nfl is 100 percent but the injury
rate is so high
that if you give guaranteed contracts it
could potentially bankrupt the sport
that's their line about that
my response to that would be that the
players deserve guaranteed contracts and
let the market pay them what uh what
they think they they're owed and let's
see what happens in that regard
but i believe that not just money though
not just the contracts i want to
underline health care as well uh should
be something that's guaranteed every
player for years after retirement
recent article in the washington post
nfl players association preparing for
lockout yeah in 2021 that's right uh
this is all on the table and we've known
this is on the table for some time
whether or not it's a lockout or a
strike will be very interesting
to see how that works but i know for a
fact that the nfl players association
has been attempting to prepare players
for years for this possibility if not
inevitability
steve is in solon ohio and you are on
book tv
mr zirin
listen i'm a 71 year old vietnam veteran
yes sir and i remember the old american
football league 1960-1959
kirk gowdy was the announcer and i loved
it
i believe that the american football
league
really left the black football players
they were really acknowledged from that
league not so much the national football
league but the american football league
really gave them acknowledge
acknowledgement
and recognition
cookie gilchrist
legend albert juvinion kim nan
bobby bale speedy duncan i remember them
all
and as far as tommy smith and john
carlos
and muhammad ali they made me very proud
of being a black man thank you
thank you so much and also solon ohio
which is the home of the great uh dave
megasy
uh who played in the national football
league and walked away from the league
uh out of actually out of protest to the
vietnam war because he felt like the
league was building up an appetite for
war
and he wrote a great book about that
called out of their league
but you know i got i love that call
because i think the history of the afl
is something that's often forgotten and
they're willing to promote uh black
players uh is also something that's
forgotten and i really appreciate that
call and i have to say like i've heard
this so often about uh tommy smith and
john carlos and and the pride that they
instilled in people for an act that they
were demonized for like it made people
feel very proud because there was this
gap that existed between how
how olympic athletes were treated
on the field you know given laurels and
medals and all the rest of it and then
how they were treated when they came
back to the united states and i'm
specifically talking about black
athletes and so to have them stand up
for that not just stand up for
themselves but stand up for people who
couldn't stand up for themselves i mean
or wouldn't stand up for themselves i
mean it's remarkable
the way in which that that's ricocheted
across the years i can't tell you how
many times i've done talks with john
carlos we toured the country together
doing interviews and someone would stand
up and they could be anywhere between
the ages of 18 and 80 and they would
talk about having that photo up on their
wall of smith and carlos raising their
fists
have you ever figured out what it costs
a community or the taxpayer to host the
super bowl game or what a super bowl
game cost the american people with the
flyovers yeah and the security the et
cetera the co the police the local
police the ot all i mean i mean it it
varies city to city in terms of the
amount of security that they feel is
needed
and the amount of security that the nfl
might demand for a particular event but
we of course are talking in the millions
of dollars i mean the flyover is alone i
believe it cost twelve thousand dollars
in gas just for the takeoffs
for the flyovers so we're talking about
a significant amount of money for the
pomp and circumstance of the super bowl
and the thing is is that people would
watch without the pomp in the
circumstance and except so many people i
mean are able to
get wealthy from it it's created this
spectacle uh really the closest thing to
uh an american religion the closest
thing to an american language uh that
transcends all barriers is people tuning
in to watch the super bowl and stuff
themselves silly are you having a super
bowl party i am
i absolutely am we're having neighbors
over uh we're going we're going to watch
the game and you know i'm gonna
uh i maintain i have nobody to root for
can't root for the patriots can't root
for the rams but you know i am going to
root for a good game and i'm going to
root for seeing my neighbors and and i'm
going to have a good time do you think
new orleans fans have a legitimate
lawsuit ensuing
absolutely my heart broke for new
orleans for folks who didn't see it
there was an obvious pass interference
call that was not called and if it had
been called new orleans would have won
that game against the los angeles rams i
know the for a fact that the city was
just utterly heartbroken when this took
place they are trying to bring lawsuits
and lawsuit was dismissed
unfortunately but i mean to me new
orleans will always have a case because
it's one of the great cities on the face
of the earth i'm not just talking about
football
jim paso robles california we have about
60 seconds for you
yes uh hello uh thank you uh mr buren
uh fascinating conversation my question
was about super bowl number three
uh
the new york jets defeated the baltimore
colts and i've heard some comments from
time to time that
fix some kind of fix must have been in
and what is your comment
no fix uh great win by the jets 16-7
and a moment that changed football
forever and also is the last super bowl
the jets have ever won so please don't
take that away from us
from bad sports dave zirin writes in the
21st century far too many sports fans
have a headache that is rapidly entering
migraine territory the headache comes
from the idea that we are loving
something that simply doesn't love us in
return yeah and i count myself among
those sometimes it can feel
incredibly rewarding and sometimes it
can feel like an abusive relationship i
think we all need to challenge ourselves
to make the abuse stop
what's your next book
i'm still trying to figure that out i'm
putting out a young adult book
with michael bennett that's based on
things that make white people
uncomfortable it's going to be
offered up in in cities and in juvenile
facilities around this country
very in schools and libraries very
excited about that as far as the next
book
i'm toying with this idea it relates to
the last caller of writing about the
mafia in sports
dave zirin has been our guest on book tv
for the past three hours thanks for your
time oh man it flew by
love it
next month on in-depth it's heather
mcdonald her most recent book is the
diversity delusion she'll be joining us
on sunday march 3rd we'll see you then
c-span where history unfolds daily
in nineteenth